this is jaco podcast number 127 with
echo Charles and me jakka willing
good evening echo good evening Iwo Jima
is to me
hallowed blessed spiritual sacred pure
ground if the spirits of the Dead could
speak what would they be saying to me
count off Marines and sailors you of the
vanquished Dead when your number reaches
seven thousand we will know that you are
present and accounted for
in this your eternal duty station serve
well your ranks are growing each passing
day as some of us your mates and war are
coming to join you those endless hours
of terrifying nights the carnage
devastation and pain turned hope into
despair the remnants of formerly dynamic
human bodies that carried hearts filled
with dreams of peace home and loved ones
after the rush of battle my eyes became
heavy with tears my body trembled with
rage as I looked upon the broken bodies
the searing invasion of human flesh
aftermath of war an elemental
suffocating fear through and through my
very soul the intensely surging
immediacy of the action was aggravated
no place to hide there was not only an
incompatibility between the Marines and
the defending Japs but the very nature
of this morbid little island the sounds
of battle which were intensified by the
human voice with all its emotions are
absent
today the moral revulsion that took
place here so many years ago has been
forgotten except by those who fought
here and survived and those who lost
lost loved ones here and that is an
excerpt from a book called hell yes I do
it again written by a man actually
written by a marine named T Fred Harvey
who fought in World War two in the
Pacific Theater including in the Battle
of Iwo Jima where he was severely
wounded for a second time but he
survived the war and has lived an
amazing life and it is an incredible
honor to have this hero here with us to
share some of the lessons that he
learned mr. Harvey
welcome to the show I'm glad to be here
I've heard a lot about this show and I'm
really pleased that you've invited me to
come here and speak to you yeah well
maybe you can just keep coming back
because we'll just sit and listen to you
we got no problem with that sir
so I guess we always try and go back to
the beginning a little bit and learn a
little bit about you and and I know your
your code up and your book has a bunch
of incredible anecdotal stories about
what it was like growing up in Texas
during the Depression so you know I was
talking to you earlier and I said people
don't know what the Depression was
really like and you described it in one
word you said hungry so that's a real
thing huh during the Depression yeah
the real thing vividly remember all the
good times while leading and the hungry
times when I was really hungry I joined
the Marine Corps that's the first time I
had adequate food satisfied with a
hunger within them here so and you you
you grew up with a single mom for the
most part so you yeah I know your dad
was doing good in construction but then
the Depression hit the Depression hit
and it really hit the Harvey family at
one time the Harvey family consisted of
seven people nine girls two boys a
father and mother and my mother was the
center of my universe when I went in
through the Marine Corps and the last
night that are spending Odesa before I
got to boot camp the train stopped in my
hometown of Odessa and they had the band
high school band and a lot of people
from town were there to greet us the
conductor said we were gonna stop for 20
minutes because the people of Odessa
want to see you off it was three of us
going to the Marine Corps at that time
when we got there there were girls there
that we're throwing kisses on me that
never dreamed to being able to even
touch not about ready to quit the Marine
Corps to say that well you know there's
some somebody grabbed my ear and jerk me
around behind the depot and it was my
mom Jesse Lee she my mom was a Comanche
Indian and she was a warrior she pulled
me around in the dark of the night
behind the outside of the crowd so
nobody could hear what she had to say
and she called me Sonny because I was so
bright
she put these this hand up in front of
me like yes right there so I can see it
she said Sonny you listen and you listen
good yes ma'am
she said number one when this war is
over
you come home to us ma'am
and don't you come home no drunkard and
you don't come home no coward
you know what that fortune was and you
don't come home with no tattoos and I
sure don't have any tattoos and that was
when she sent me off to San Diego and
I'll tell you a little bit later in this
session she came out to see me and
you'll see the reason why she came out
to see me
so you actually at at one point and I
thought that was a real interesting
thing because it seemed like you got a
lot of weight on your shoulders as a
young as a youngster and I'm gonna go to
the book here for a minute I greeted my
mom cheerfully she avoided my eyes and
this is just you coming home from school
a degree to my mom cheerfully as usual
she avoided my eyes and wiped her home
with her apron I noted with concern a
puffy redness about them she got up and
went to the oven and brought out a baked
potato and a big bowl of pinto beans
thanking her I dug in in silence she
entered that same bedroom my thoughts
centered wholly on the food without
preamble I heard a loud beseechingly
desperate cry come through the closed
door no Jessie not that and that was
your dad with a gasp I spewed a mouthful
of food knocked over the small table and
went through the door without benefit of
the knob in the dimly lit bedroom I
viewed a scene of heart choking horror a
picture forever etched in my memory my
father desperately grappled for the
pistol my mother tried to bring down on
herself or him without wavering or
hesitation I lunged at her with all the
force I could muster like
with a fist to the side of her head she
sang at the knees dropped the pistol and
fell forward inert she laid down on the
floor I was horrified by what I had done
my father staggered back and slumped
whimpering into a corner I headed to the
bathroom and came out with a bath towel
sopping wet with cold water I applied it
to her suffering face until she came
around unsteadily I helped her to her
feet and then seated her on the side of
the bed
all the while dad remained in the corner
- shaking to get up or offer any
assistance - shaking to get up or offer
any assistance sobbing I cried why
mother why why with a clear steady voice
she said your daddy does not love us
anymore he has another woman it's a lot
of lot for a young kid to deal with
yeah the saddest moment in my whole life
I'll never forget that
and my mom was a great mom she held the
family together after he left us he
applied the for divorce and I went to
the judges chamber with my mother and
the judge calls us me and my father to
come to him and my mom was too weak to
get up together go to the judge the
judge said mr. Harvey I'm granting your
divorce
the six remaining children and her
family will remain with their mother and
you will pay in the sum of 42 dollars
for child care a month for six children
and herself and that was the last penny
my dad ever spent on us and
we just abort him cleared completely
from our minds and so forth I had
nothing to do with him after that and
there was the saddest moment of my whole
life when that happened and it was
interesting to you mentioned later in
the book that you could have gotten
because now you were like the sole
supporter of the family you could have
actually gotten a deferment from going
to the war yes uh-huh and and your mom
like didn't give it to you or she knew
that you wanted to go in the Marine
Corps yeah well for while she held off
wouldn't sign the papers for me to go
see I was just sophomore in high school
and I was failing all my subjects
because I was trying to hold down two
jobs to hit my mom and my sisters and it
was it was hard times it was really bad
for us all but my mom Hill the rest of
us together and and I'll be able to
through it and they did so your mom knew
that you wanted to join the Marine Corps
yeah and she thought they owned it and
one day my cousin came home and I went
to the recruiting office with him and he
signed up because he was old enough to
sign and I took the papers home to my
mom she was at the clothesline hanging
up wet clothes to be dried you know and
I put that paper in front of her I said
this is for you to sign when she decided
now because I'm going into the Marine
Corps she'd lead that wet towel on the
basket walked down our to the end of the
line I'd built her a line for drying
clothes and there was some excess wire
six strand
she took that thing and twisted it into
it
long whip-like things came back to me
took my left hand in her left hand and
whacked me cross to the rear and I made
a complete circle around it and I
stopped and glared at her and I could
see that she was shedding tears the
first years of it had ever seen her said
that broke my heart
and I stood there for a while and she
turned and walked and went through the
house and then I cried I cried hard and
so about a week later I came home from
school and she handed me a paper that
she had signed for me to go into the
Marine Corps and so that was the birth
of my marine corps how old were you I
was 17 okay I was 17 and and I couldn't
pass English and so I quit school and
joined the Marine Corps before where
were you and where were you when Pearl
Harbor happened so that was what a year
prior no I was in school but it was a
Sunday day and Jake Rhodes my buddy had
a little coop right there and we had
dates and we called her big birthers the
little coop was too small for all of us
to sit abreast of each other so I said
on her lap I just waited 118 pounds and
she popped out waiting about five or six
hours and we heard that Pearl Harbor had
been attacked and that that was a day
that I learned that I was gonna be
and involved in a war because of age you
know and so how would you heard about
the Marine Corps as opposed to the army
or the Navy well I wanted to be a
paratrooper and then I thought I'd go
into the army and be a paratrooper then
I found out that the Marines had
paratroopers so I joined the Marine
Corps instead and I found me a home yeah
so you you leave on that train your mom
tells you you know don't be a coward
don't get any tattoos don't be a
drunkard yeah and come home to us these
are good basic fundamental rules for a
lot of people I think to follow and you
head off on that train to boot camp
which is right here in San Diego
California
yes so I got through boot camp okay but
a big problem when they land us up we
fitted out with shoes and clothes and
everything when it came to the shoes out
there they made was there and they said
son you can't join the Marine Corps cuz
their feet are too small and I thought
well gosh he not gonna send me home is
eating everything i Worf sighs
five-and-a-half issue and he said we
just don't make she was that small and
so I had an old pair of shoes that had
worn out should have been thrown away
and I played a lot of Poker I knew how
to play poker before and you maybe seeds
well then where I catch that cards
around all the time so when I went ring
Corps I had to use the whole deck
putting about three in through my shoes
that had holes in them my civilian shoes
that had holes in them and and they
finally one night I'd always take the
top bunk in whoever I went there what
barracks I was in you know
put my shoes on the deck under the bunk
next morning I woke up and there was the
touch somebody had taken a car tire tire
and cutout sold for me the thing was
about that thick you know so had a pair
of shoes that I could march in anyway
and then when I had to cut down my
dungarees cut down you know because it's
too big and so forth
and I had a lot of trouble because I was
so small and the other at one time I was
small enough that Ralph hauled my
captain or my platoon leader he was the
first lieutenant at that time and not
for various picked me as the runner and
so one night we just sitting around the
campfire and and I said why don't pick
me as a as you as a runner and they said
well you were so small so you made a
small target and he was so fast afoot
that you could run outrun any [ __ ] in the
roar in the world so the reason I was
made a count a company runner so you
were saying that your mom it's in the
book - it's a great story about your mom
bringing you something to bootcamp
visiting you been bringing you something
to bootcamp
oh yeah well it wasn't exactly the boot
camp is when I came back from overseas
and the found out that there's going to
be in a demolition man in there soaked
squad and the social squad was composed
of five men with specials and I was
going to be a demolition man I was
supposed to carry so many pounds of
demolition on my back and and on in
front I would carry my regular pack you
know so
for me so I couldn't handle a rifle so
at first I said well we've tried to get
you a pistol because it couldn't handle
a rifle
with all that weight and so forth
and he said we're going to get you a
pistol I've waited around a week for a
pistol and finally came out said the
Marine Corps doesn't have any pistols
any any left and so I was desperate so I
called my mom I said mom find me a
pistol I'd like to have a colt 1911 cold
and my mom went out and looked all over
town well I looked all over San Diego
here for a pistol myself and there just
wasn't one that we had you know and so I
called my mom and told her what I needed
and she senators the money I sent her
seventy-five dollars that I'd won in a
poker game I sent that to her and she
went around all over town looking for a
pistol couldn't find one until she came
to a trailer house down close to the
railroad tracks
with a guy that had a gun shop there so
she went at the house trailer and
knocked on the door and mr. Armstrong
came out and said what do you need ma'am
she says I need a pistol
what kind of pistol do you need she said
she took out the piece of paper that I
written it on called 45 1911 and he said
I just happened to have one of those and
she said how much is it and he said $200
and she said I can't afford that
he said well that's all that God why do
you need such a big pistol she said well
my son is in a Marine Corps and he needs
a pistol and so he said well this is the
only one I have but two hundred dollars
and in solution she backed it out of the
door and went down room
mr. Armstrong came down to talk to us
she said he said he said his son was in
the Marine Corps and and needs a pistol
said surely they can give him a pistol
and she said no they don't have any and
she said well come on back we'll work up
a deal so she walked out with that
pistol cleaned of cosmoline and he had
his seventy-five dollars and she needed
to get there as soon as he could you
know so she went down to the bus station
got on the bus with a paper grocery bag
in it with extra clothes you know and
got on the bus and 36 hours later she
got the San Diego now she crisscross
because in those days you know military
guys had priority and she'd be in one
place they would bump her off let a guy
come in take a place and see crisscross
you may stay in Arizona for 36 hours
well we're loading up to go overseas and
covered arts and I were up on the truck
with a bunch of see bags and Fisher my
sergeant at that time was sitting in the
cab with the driver and everything so we
went through the gate over Camp
Pendleton and eight guards said is there
any marine up our named har
Fred Harvey and Cobra woke me up I was
asleep woke me up said hey they're
calling for your names so looked over
and I saw my mom look up at me and nice
little thing real fast
I came over real fast well after a while
Fisher said it's hard we got to gotta go
I want to let your mom sit in the seat
I'll get up i with yellow and so we
drove down town and was looking for a
place for her to stay we couldn't find a
place anywhere I mean we tried every
hotel and so forth so finally I this is
around twelve o'clock at night and so I
went to a policeman and I said sir can
you tell me where we might find a place
for my mom to stay hotel or a motel or
something you know and he said well I
just don't know of any place and so
forth I'll tell you what I'll call my
wife
if your mother was stayed with her I'll
call her and we'll go out there and so
the wife said yes bringing been around
so he called off office in the police
car came out and drove into the house
and his wife well welcomed us with open
arms you know and she stayed there three
different nights and and then I was able
to Fischer would let me off quite a bit
at the time there was three days that
she was there and then she finally had
to put her on the bus and he wrote her
know making the priority she wouldn't be
bumped and the thing when she got home
we loved was a story of how I got my
pistol
and it was shortly thereafter that you
went on you had it overseas
yes uh-huh and that was on a on a formal
former cattle ship is that that was the
first time I went overseas okay so you
came back in between in between so that
you got the pistol after your first time
going overseas yeah it was the second
time I went overseas okay what's the
first time I went over was on the Blume
fun team okay you want to hear about the
Blume Fontaine well I read about it and
it's a pretty nasty story in many ways
oh that was a nasty [ __ ] hey but I
thought that's what it was you know I
hadn't seen ocean until I've gotten in
the Marine Corps and so they they put us
on on the bloom Fontaine and they've
been a cattle ship a Dutch at a Dutch
captain and he was he shipped I mean he
transferred cattle from Australia over
to through the Dutch Holdings in the
South Pacific well when the war broke
out he had just dumped out a load of
cattle and when he found out it was at
war well he headed for San Francisco you
know he got to San Francisco he offered
it to the Navy and the Navy took it made
it into a troop ship they didn't clean
that stuff up very good you know they
shouldered it out and they left a lot of
stuff and they just painted over it of
course when it started selling that [ __ ]
wood buckling and everything and that
cow droppings is ever forever you know
and the bunks were stocked up eight high
and I was lucky I was small enough to
get in there without any trouble a lot
of those little guys couldn't get in and
the head you know or the Navy and
Marine Corps that the bathroom is called
the head you know the head was just a
long shed from the bow of the ship back
to the holding say you know where the
captain stood and so forth and what had
happened they'd made a tray of what yeah
doctor for water would flow down the
thing right and they had a pipe for you
to sit on whether you just sit on that
pipe and then do you thing and get up
and leave you know well that thing broke
down and so here we were out at sea with
no way to dispose of you know the
droppings well anyway so the Dutch
captain signed this crude set make
things on the front of this about the
ship and it kind of like saddles deals
on the side of a horse you know you just
go up her and drop your pants and sit
down on that thing and and doctor didn't
feed the fish you know well I was too
viable to go out to and use that because
there were 13 naval nurses on that same
ship and they set up and I held office I
was trying to hold off to a dark I was
too embarrassed to go but finally I had
to go so different opened all my pants
like the rest of them did well yeah you
know when you're floating along now
you're going up and down first thing you
know your butt is in the water and it
comes back a lot and you didn't really
need toilet paper because you didn't
need them because there wasn't any on
there that was a problem the whole time
I was in Marine Corps overseas was
toilet paper oh that was something but
that's the way we travel there and when
you go through the our seasick our
seasick all the time
they put bin in the sickbay and for some
reason there were lots of high hole
crackers in there I don't know what it
was doing on a troopship but they were
so lonely and so I'd eat a couple of
those every hour and they'd hide them or
nobody else could get them and was on
that ship for 29 days to get the new
caledonia and one day the ship broke
down here we are drifting that time we
drifted for probably 30 or 40 hours you
know and was taking bets that's where we
were drift to in South America and and
they they get past the word out that
we're sports a keeper life belts on them
at all times
and keep your eyes looking out for
submarines because we didn't have any
ESCO we just out there by ourselves and
over slow cattle ship and we is in real
trouble and and we drifted for 72 hours
and they finally got the engine going
again so here we are going to overseas
we didn't know where we were going you
know and then we got a scare that there
was possibly a [ __ ] submarine in the area
so we pulled into the nearest island we
were close to you know we pulled in
there and I fell in love without that
island
it was Tonga to food and just went in
either one of these things you see in
the movies you know and we pulled in
that Bay and dropped anchor and here the
natives came out paddling canoes and
they had coconut pineapple a lot of
fruit stuff but I'd sell them up our to
us and then we fight for so saying well
anyway they came
came back that night and entertained us
on the deck of the ship we were sitting
around there and they were they doing
their dances the hula dancers and it was
a beautiful island I mean it is
beautiful and I swore brother I said to
myself it Harvey there's a lot more in
this world than Odessa Texas and I'm
going to see some of it before I die and
so they put on the show and at last they
sang their island song you know what it
was you are my sunshine and we pulled
away from there and we got started then
we stopped went back what's going on six
guys had jumped ship it went to show
Herbert draw him back well I didn't
think about jumping ship fun thought
about it I'm out of joy and so we pulled
out finally got to New Caledonia he'd
been at sea for 29 days and we as old
tickle to finally get there but that
ship was a hell ship you know and when
we got there they took us off the ship
and this is now in New Caledonia your
caldo and so you're a couple months out
of boot camp at this point yeah okay and
this is the first place you stop and and
you're gonna basically just for people
that don't know you're gonna get to New
Caledonian you're gonna kind of train
and prepare for for going out and taking
down some islands yeah well there was
two reasons we went to we gonna farm up
with the rest of the troops you know the
first parachute battalion was already
there in fact they were involved in
Guadalcanal and
so we were going down how to replace the
guys so I was went to the first person
battalion they were 60 miles from the
base that we came in on I can't remember
the base that we landed at or the port
we landed at but it was a capital of New
Caledonia and our the parachute
battalions were stationed out all about
60 miles from nouméa
yeah you mayor was a capital of that
place and then once you got this is that
where you met your your that were you
joined up you're saying with your
parachute company yeah yeah I was
assigned to the first parachute
battalion in did you did you if I
remember correct you go to Guadalcanal
this at this point no we went later when
we went up to our first action together
after Guadalcanal was we were supposed
to go to Belo la vella anything so we're
on our way up there we stopped off at
Guadalcanal okay and that's after what a
canal had been secured you know and so
they let a scrimmage we went up to find
some of the old guys that had escaped
Japanese had escaped and we didn't see
anything so we didn't get to shoot any
Japs so we were there a couple of days
and we got up for chow one morning just
about before sunup and everything and I
was up front of the line I'd always
managed to get the front of the line for
Chow yeah for child yeah you you've
mentioned cool throughout the book that
you're a guy that liked your child oh I
love child I was trying to catch up with
her The Hunger I'll had then during the
Depression well anyway he's in line
waiting to go in to get child you know
and then I heard a lot of laughing and
carrying on back to the lines
I read never sees what the action was
you know and there's three bedraggled
Japanese had just come out of line out
of the jungle and got in line and an
officer got that came down it and that
could speak Japanese and they he said
they were hungry and everything so they
took my part fed them and they kept them
there I guess as long as they needed
them they was washing pots and pans and
doing work then when we left and so
forth
and they got off flight and so as you
were preparing to go now you're working
you had a couple guys that you mentioned
in the book you know I'll start with the
first one I'm gonna mention three of
them major Fagan fate for gand is that
he say again ya Yin major Fagan he
sounds like one tough customer he was
too man he was I was scared I'd see him
coming down you know the trilled or
anything like that I'd jump in the jug
or keep with me because I was scared of
him well everybody was scared because he
was tough he just drove us he found out
that Japanese March with full packs and
a 24-hour prepared March 39 miles he
said we're going to beat that and we
marched 50 miles with full packs at our
own new caledonia and we would walk up
the hills and trot down the
heels came down and we went 50 miles and
I don't know whether it's any kind of
record book or anything but we was proud
of it yeah so forth I don't know if it's
a record book either but I know it hurt
yeah
now you also did a couple you tell a
couple stories in the book about him but
he put you is he had no problem putting
people on bread and water all no problem
no problem no in fact I was put on bread
and water I had a buddy there that was
went through the parachute platoon with
me right Ernie he nearly got us killed
the thing I won't give him yeah his name
you know but he passed away several
years ago I don't want to say anything
we don't want to incriminate his ass
well he when was going through parachute
school his name was well I'll tell you
his name last name his name was Harmon
so when we lined up alphabetically and
everything we did you know well he's
always right behind me so when we went
to parachute school we wound up together
you know because of her name's have been
real close to one another well anyway
now when we jumped Marine Corps jumped
from the plane we know about headfirst
their theory was that when you jump out
and that parachute opens or I tell you
kind of swing with it
well the army jumped him out feet first
and came down so forth so we jumped him
we jumped out headfirst we were training
there and out here in camp Gillespie
that's worthy purser school laws and we
lined up and made to make our first jump
will Harmon was behind me well in the
plane we had we called it the blue
Goo's now we had to borrow that from the
Navy because Marine Corps didn't own any
planes itself so we used the Blue Goose
so they took us out there in a truck you
know the guys that had volunteered to go
into the parachute school and that truck
driver Dover southbound and and the
barracks and the officers and everything
was at the top of this hill and below
was the runway and that's where the
where we jumped into that area right
there that drivers over up on and stop
real fast he said they're fixing jump
you guys wanna watch and so well jumped
out of the truck there's about 10 and 15
of us you know jumped out of the truck
watch them it flew over man here they
come diving out one of them was coming
down fast here were flailing like this
his parachute didn't open and so just
before he hit the deck that parachute
opened he had to pull out his his
reserve chute now the reserve chute was
on the front and it didn't have a pilot
chute on it so when you pull a rip party
is supposed to pull out that silk
yourself what wasn't the seal kit was
nylon well he was pulling that out just
he got it filled out he hit the deck and
a jeep was on this way down there and
they put it put him in that Jeep put a
parachute on him got him on the plane
plane went up out he came again and that
truck driver said any of you guys were
gonna go back to boot camp and two guys
got back on the truck and went back and
I thought seriously buddies I want to
know and that's not a good initiation
into parachute jump that's reserved yeah
well we had to pack our own chutes he
learned how to pack suits and we and
every step you took a parachute school
you had to be running if you weren't
running an officer NCO would catch you
you were in trouble you know so every
step we took we learned how to pack
shoots right and up and down I got where
I could pack a chute in 12 minutes
one day they said you're gonna pack a
shoot today and you're going to jump to
tomorrow and I said I better take a
little bit more time so it took me 30
minutes to do that
well that night
Oh what was that
Indians name but IRA Hayes he was in the
my platoon new pastor you heard I don't
pay his hip raise the flag on evil he
was real quiet and there was another
ending in there with him and that night
before we jumped that guy jumped off and
hollered gung ho you know and broke both
of his ankles so that ended his pursuit
but I was a it was a good marine
he was quiet you know he'd never never
said much I'd talk to him you know
because my mom was a Comanche Indian I
had some Indian blood you know I'm not
tell him that you know and and we became
close friends but he's so quiet you know
this great great guy but this is quiet
whether you know the history of what he
did you know what happened to avoid guy
yeah well anyway we came out and that
first jumper made we made the jump and
when I came out I don't want my chute
opened I was standing on another shoot
she below me was Harmon he should have
been above me because he's coming out
there well we didn't think much about it
you know I just started us with jumping
was like well the next day we jumped
again and we came up we were tangled
together and and there shoots you know
when there's slanting up like that air
was going up too fast you know when
holding this Sheba to pray and when we
hit man is like a ton of bricks hitting
you know man it hurt another thing
because that she doesn't wasn't able to
those shoots weren't able to hold us up
so we hit the ground pretty hard to jump
masters and the guy on the deck watch
something that's what happened and I
don't know if they didn't ask anything
of Harman you know he's always meeting
looking at you know well anyway
but in fact it's looking at me because I
didn't even have boots on their $1.00
where's your boots I said y'all don't
having it they were fit me so he finally
got me a pair of a six size and told me
to wear four pair of socks you know I
was in first boots ahead
well back to Harman well the next time
would jump I came out and bruised up and
everything and when a jump will I was my
shoot at the shroud lines in channel
tangled up in my boot you know so I
whipped out the k-bar knife and cut
those two strands of rope being older
let me down just before I hit the ground
world I got my feet down first you know
they come running over her to me and
what is going on there what's happening
I don't know and so what had happened
when my purse shoot when I jumped out
our dough Laval of the thing right there
I was facing the plane and my sad
decline was playing out between my legs
and so Lou got tangled up in the cerrado
lines man they came up burning they
decided I was too light to be in and in
a part shoot you know and so the
sergeant over there at they at the loft
for we packed our chutes you know he and
officer were talked and he said well
he's just too light and and I was
standing there talking about I said
I said y'all can't kick me out I want to
stay in this outfit I want to stay in it
nothing
and so that sergeant he said why don't
we put him in a Army Navy canopy now the
Army Navy canopy was only twenty six
feet diameter and the the ones we used
the nylons no one's used was 28 you know
we're just a bigger canopy and
everything so this guy took an Army Navy
parachute took it out and put it it only
all the carriage you know I forget what
they call it you know where you folded
you shoot and put it all night and so
here I am with a with a parachute you
know made out of silk and instead of
nylon and silk reacts lot faster than
nylon does so so when that sheet opened
I got a pretty good kick out of it well
when we came out and that day we were
gonna jump with weapons and so they gave
us all a risin gun you ever heard of
horizon gun no it's about as worthless
as a grease gun so we called him your
grease gun it was a terrible weapon they
they outlawed him in the in the military
right quick well anyway I had one of
those and when I went out the door the
Harmon hit me and knocked my that rising
gun down it went down stuck in the dirt
and they they this is a our fourth jump
and and the sergeant said they were they
were considering just really drop me
send me back to boot camp tour be
assigned somewhere else you know with
tears and my begged him let me stay you
know well in then the sergeant said
I'm gonna go up tomorrow
and watch and see what is happening and
so he went up and found out what was
happening I hear we're coming down this
white line and the fuselage of the plane
and then their white line was right
there leading out the door so we were
supposed to come down and make a sharp
turn and dive out well I was coming down
down and going out to a proper way
Harlen was coming down there and he was
cutting across and he was going through
the door at the same time I was and it
was knocking me against the side over
there and and he's just knocked me honey
he he was a suitor was opening for mine
was opening and so we got that
straightened out and and that wasn't the
only trouble I had with Harmon but
that's a different story or maybe I
shouldn't bring it up here so you
actually you actually talked about when
you did find to get your first jump
everything went good and you said you
know I had never made first-string in
any sport because of my size but when
they pinned those wings on my chest and
shoved a rifle into my hands I had at
last made first string with that rifle
in my hands sighs no longer seemed
relevant I had made the team and found a
home the Marine Corps filled all my
dreams and all my needs Harmon actually
ended up getting you in trouble
Yeah right while you were in New
Caledonia yeah well I won't go into the
pink house but I do in the book don't I
don't know our day off was Wednesday
first battalion got Wednesday off you
know they didn't let us all off at the
same time because they didn't or another
Pearl Harbor type thing because the Japs
are still on the offensive at that time
so he he got where he would go down
there every Wednesday and he fell in
love one of those
girls and they fell in love or she fell
in love with him but he went in there
and he didn't get the bus but last truck
going back to base and he didn't get
back in time so he had to hitchhike I
don't know how he got there but he got
to her about all about an hour after
roll call and everything so when he
showed up
well Fagan just put him on five days
bread and water feeding don't play
around yeah well when you buy it would
buy something move out from the PX you
couldn't go in and buy one bar a candy
or one can of beans or anything like you
had to buy a whole box so on his third
day I went went over and got me a Jill
boy now Joe wood was a non chocolate you
couldn't have chocolate candy in the
tropics because it melts you know so
they had this new get covered with
peanuts and it's called Joe boy some
went by there one night man open up not
as eating one of them two holidays him
through the barbed wire thing he was in
a tent and it was kind of in a clearing
in the woods you know he said tell me
one of those things I am had anything
but bread and water for three days now I
said no I'm not gonna throw you guys
against the root aw come on please I
would do it for you just kept on so I
looked around took to him out until the
line corporal of the guard thinking
they'd seen me well he came over and he
said put this guy in there and unfairest
happened to be the corporal of the guard
at that time and he said well we can't
we're all packed up you know we don't
have they're just one buck one thing you
caught in there and arrest them are all
packed ready to go and said there's no
place for
to sleep easy we'll take that guy out
and put the guy in there and so the next
day I was sitting there oh how did I
don't really had a couple loaves of
bread and water he came by with a box of
candy I said come on show me one of
those things I just know that's against
the rules I don't want to get in trouble
he never did so one over to cold blooded
yeah now you were gonna get sort of
written up for that and lieutenant Hall
who you know you got a lot of respect
for I'm going back to the book here he
is now you're checking in with
lieutenant hall and he's supposed to
write you up and put this in your
permanent record yeah and he says Harvey
he said with a document in hand I was
ordered to write you up but I can't put
it in your records as all the records
have been stowed away to remain here
I'll have to carry this paper with me
and it will surely get lost in the
jungle before we get back to
civilization again I got a knowing smile
and a pat on the back now get out of
here and forget what has happened get
your gear and order I think we're taking
a boat ride I gave him the smartest
salute possible and said thank you sir I
appreciate what you've done for me I
think I might have skipped to my 10th
filled with a deep joy and the
deliciousness of being a Marine
I left my troubles behind me and soon
got to feel the thrill of combat I
realized soon after in the heat of
battle that the harsh demanding training
of that major Richard Fagan Sergeant
Ferris and Lieutenant Ralph F Hall put
us through paid off we performed well
under fire Ferris and Fagan received
wounds in the Battle of Iwo Jima
Lieutenant Hall died in the Battle of
Iwo Jima I shed bitter tears when I
heard the news of his death he was a
great marine at Iwo Fagan earned the
Navy Cross as we fought for Bougainville
sergeant Ferris did some amazing things
for which he received the coveted Silver
Star later at the battle for Iwo here in
the Bronze Star and Purple Heart medals
then he went on to win his second Silver
Star and Purple Heart during the Korean
War
hack this guy hung around to fight in
the Vietnam in Vietnam in the 1960s a
Marine Marines Marine I found serving
with him a great honor one of the high
points of my life even today 70 plus
years later we get together from time to
time what do we talk about of course the
war and our buddies of that bygone era
so you had I thought that was just a
great leadership story about how
lieutenant Hall just said hey you know
what we're gonna we're gonna shred this
document and it never happened and then
you move to your first was it your first
combat was being in Bougainville Novello
the Vela was okay
yeah and what was what was going into
Bella Bella Bella
what was it Bella la Vella Vella la
Vella well you know we were island
hopping over there what we would do
would evade an island put in an airstrip
and everything and to use to hop to the
next Island because it didn't when we
were still reading it's nearly vacated
that an all-out they our feel that with
you padeen and everything and so Vella
LaBella was one of those stages and
everything and across the bay there I
think is something like 13 miles or
something was : bangerra now that was
just an island just sticking up volcanic
island just sticking up in the ocean and
it was all the [ __ ] occupied it and but
we took Bella love Bella and put in an
airstrip there we landed there and that
was when I had my first taste of action
we moved in to the Isle due to the
jungle and they Seabees we're supposed
to follow us in you know and start
building there well the Seabees was
tough outfit they were getting ahead of
us and we've had to hear she'll die
so they made a ask us get on the put
snipers on the their tractors and that's
what we did never thing but then we move
when we were moving out of the Bates
well we had send out of there patrolled
because we've had and when we invaded we
didn't run into any Japs but we found
that there were some up bar so we were
going to go up and attack them before
they could get down and and work over
the Seabees that were building the
airstrip you know and so it was so hot
in the jungle were so thick we had to
have guys using match it's you know to
chop our way through there well we last
only about 10 minutes using those
choppers to get through there
they're just big blades you know just
use you just chop through the vines well
we were staggered the guy was here I was
here and then another guy was here and
we were working our way through it
and and the [ __ ] Nambu opened up on us
and this job was up in a tree and he
shot and it killed these two guys that
was in this line over here and I was
over here so they didn't get us yet at
all three of us well anyway then he went
out to me and I just jumped under the
threads and the brush and everything and
I just crawled for one place or other
and I don't think he could see me but he
was probably to see the leaves and
braces working he is firing at me and
everything and so a guy a big guy had an
a4 machine gun you know that's an air
cold 30 caliber weapon and he had a
bestest glove and he was big enough for
strong
enough that he could fire a short bust
at a time with it and everything so he
said Harvey what tree is that guy in I
said that big one over here on the left
he said that doesn't mean a thing
they're all big on the left and right
and so I said fire at one of the rods oh
now I'll give you directions where to go
so I got fired at me and they saw the
four he was shooting out so this guy I
wish I could think of his name this big
guy admired him could he is so being
strong but he just saturated that thing
that a four machine gun and sure now
fear came a [ __ ] hanging that he had a
rope around his foot and that Nambu
machine gun nuts first that weapon not
seen that's first time I've been shot at
you know so I remember the name move
real well well anyway as well was my
first action and man I hated those jet
machine guns but if I had to go to war
right now I would get me out [ __ ] Nambu
machine gun and there's a picture about
there that weapon was something else and
she had a magazine to hold 20 sales and
Luke and I ran across another one at Iwo
Jima and that's another story and but
and then then you guys pretty much
mopped up that first operation then
there wasn't too much resistance now
there wasn't too much resistance and
then and then you moved on after that
was that when you had it to Bougainville
that the night we went to Mogan Vale
after that you got an interesting story
in about about Bougainville that kind of
thinks worst might be worth talking
about a little bit because it kind of
shows how you know war is not always
what it's made out to be in the movies
so here we're going you you were
actually speaking a toilet-paper and in
this particular situation you were just
done getting done you'd gone to relieve
yourself by a little house and then you
hear the order I heard the order move
out on the double as I stood between the
house and the banyan tree buckling my
belt something in the vague misty light
caused caught my eye I stood in rapt
amazement as a guy came diligently down
the tree I could see that he had only a
piece of cloth around his waist when he
reached the bottom he bent forward as if
to pick up a sandal I watched an utter
wonderment as this scene played out
before me just a little guy when he
straightened up I stepped up and brought
my rifle stock across the back of his
head with a glancing blow he turned as
he crumpled and landed fully on his back
I looked down and to my horror found
myself looking at a female instead of a
male stunned and shaken by my act I
choked on a sob and trembled
uncontrollably what had I done as I
stood there bathed in pity and
compassion all hell broke loose the
shatter and clatter of small-arms fire
broke the silence trying hard to choke
back the sobs I raced to join the fire
fight glad to leave that pitiful
pathetic scene and act an outnumbering
force pinned us down all day although
desperately busy during this time my
thoughts kept going back to the base of
that banyan tree at midday our
ammunition ran low the sergeant ordered
me back to the rear to find more I
veered from a direct path to the beach
to pass by that tree of infamy I found
neither her nor her body I quickly ran
around the tree and under the house to
no avail
I ventured up the steps to look inside
the house inside it looked like an
infirmary or aid station but empty I
hope that I had only stunned her and she
had walked away from the area after the
incident I gave a great deal of thought
to that lady in the Coconut Grove
definitely of oriental heritage I
wondered her purpose there I thought of
several possibilities she could have
served
as a nurse in the Japanese military or a
resident of the island brought there by
the late lever brothers soap company to
work in the coconut groves also she
might come from Korea one of the many
Korean women kidnapped by the Japs to
serve as prostitutes for their military
no matter the reason I hope and pray
that she survived the blow to her head
and the war in my lifespan I've stored
many many items in my arsenal of
memories the memory of that day so very
long ago rests among my most vivid the
memorable events on that lonely Beach on
the far side of planet Earth have not
dimmed over time nor distance it all
took place because I crawled beneath a
house I think I lost the last vestige of
the little boy within me that day yeah
that was really tough for me you know it
I remembered my sisters you know and and
thought to have terrible it would be if
they were hit like that and it stuck
with me all of these years you know I
remember that little little lady in that
jungle that was another story there we
were setting up her what was the name of
that beach Corie Corie beach we had
heard that the Japs were fixing to come
up our so was he since 1st battalion
upper and a company of Raiders up and we
went up I left our base at about 12
o'clock and there's 12 miles up the
island and when we invaded evaded it
during the night we wait until the
beginning to get light well there was a
Japanese an officer came in walked into
the group I didn't see him I because I
was out on the flank but it was a
Japanese officer he came down there
hollering instructions and everything
and he didn't know it was Marines that
had come ashore he thought it was
thinking because they were building up
to invade that area where we revealed in
the airstrip snow and so they shot him
dead right there and then all hell broke
loose because we were outnumbered 10 to
1 and when I finished with doing my job
and hurting that little girl
well I rent catch up with the bus you
know well the first guy got caught up
with whitey mains and he was in and my
company and everything so we went on a
burn and we used on the very end flanks
and we both had Johnson rifles and
that's all we had to protect that flank
with and that's a weak part of the line
and haul came up by oh I'd say about
nine or ten o'clock he said what y'all
doing down here you're supposed to be up
our with us and they had gone on up and
we worked be company we were with B
company and a company was in the middle
of the of the group you know and so he
just said well stay here and I'll get
get an A for down here to protect this
flank you know the flank is the weak
point of the lion said y'all protect it
well it was a coconut girl that we hit
into and they had a road behind that
Coconut Grove and those Japs were using
that whole material up prior to invade
that airstrip and so here Wiley and I
were on the flanker and that's where we
detected well it began to send planes
Dino they were straight from that road
that we were struck out along you know
and those planes were coming hard and
fastest
and come up our protectors they better
wiped us out a whole regiment of Japs
are fixing to invade that deal what time
and those planes were coming just one
after another and they didn't bother to
put up their landing gears they just
left them down and it's come along
strafe David to drop bombs along the way
and we were on the very end we we've
afraid there's gonna start their
shooting before they got to we'd get out
there and wave I don't write there and
they go by signal here at us and start
strafing and we were there all day long
and and the commander done that at the
Dyer base told him to do that just
sending it up Krause to take us off and
thinkin's answered no we're not going to
be the first man Marines to be pushed
off of a beach we were scheduled to be
taking off at 7 o'clock and that's when
we will start boarding over books so we
was out all day long and it was a long
day and haul it came up our few times
and we had Johnson rifles we didn't have
the n1 rifle we had dirt johnson
ralpherz a 30 caliber cylinder fed same
didn't used clips in them now thought it
was the best weapon that I had but in
the in the war beside the Nambu and
Hollywood bring us ammunition up there
and then he finally come up there late
in the afternoon he said you guys make
this last because there's we're nearly
out of ammunition and so here we were
and was couldn't do anything until 7
o'clock so we ships Higgins boats were
out there circling waiting for 7 o'clock
I guess because then
odd fares came up and he said now we're
gonna be taking off and we were started
at 7 o'clock that's about an hour and a
half from now and the guys next to you
there in Company B now because the
mix-up you know why he means and I was
involved in well anyway on first told us
that when these guys over here they're
gonna leave and when they leave they're
gonna holler and let you know that
they're leaving you count to 50 as fast
as you can and then get down to the
beach okay so we sit there or sit there
we hear these boats coming in and taking
off and shooting and everything on it
Rutter has of white Akash what time is
we should be getting out of here and
everything and why I said hollered over
at those other guys are telling they
didn't answer us so I walked over there
they'd already left and didn't call it
out so here we were only two guys left
on the beach I guess and we started
running well I was pretty fast so I took
why this Johnson rifle and I cared both
of them down there and I still beat him
down to the bus I mean through that
higgins boat but that when the Higgins
boat it was say it was what LCVP LC VT
is heavier than the Higgins boat is all
steel right there so here we are running
down there and hollering don't leave
don't leave and everything well odd
Ferris was on the deck and and the ramp
on that the LSB was at about a 45 degree
angle because that was taking shots from
the Japs and out Ferris was they died no
he didn't and
and Captain Hayes he captained by this
time he was trying to hold her something
everything and Fagin was on that boat
and this little toxin on the thing right
there said we're moving out okay we're
leaving not faking city forties void
feed because the guys down there put
that pistol in that kid's hand put this
back on blow your bleep head off so he
put it back on there and the guys that
around that they there's telling us
about what happened and so here we are
running and so forth and I got down
there and articles to rifles through
them up up there into the boat and Hall
got him to Lord a little bit throughout
the thing in odd fares Turkish tickets
for our foot you know and heaved us up
and haul put her sewing in and I got a
burn here or why the mains finally got
that and that's how we got off the
island but you held the line until 7
o'clock yeah as you were ordered yeah
yeah it took about 30 to 40 minutes I
guess to get everybody off their knew we
were the last to get off the island and
I'd been on the beach before it night
not in one will be on a beach again and
Japanese territory now once you got back
on the boat or you got back out now the
next thing to do is prepare for you oh
well we got back they took so we got
back on a destroyer and was heading back
in to impress Augustus Bay that was on
Bougainville us where we invaded have
set up a airstrip you know to attack New
Guinea but anyway
we got the word I'll forget the exactly
when he got it that is breaking up the
paratroopers we're coming back to the
States
okay and so we got back to the states
and was integrated into the fifth
division
okay well that's interesting that you
saw that this is when you told the whole
story about your mom coming to bring you
45 this is when this is now happening
yeah okay that one and did you did you
guys just sailed back to America
yeah we came on back to America who his
own Liberty ships okay and and they got
goddess backed Pendleton and we got a
little leave I don't know how long it
was it might have been 30 days leave you
know and and we started forming up in
the fifth division and that's when I
when we got back I was I had what they
call the crud you know I broke out all
over a body it just like having
athlete's foot on the old wadding and so
they brought us back and and another
story Larry might I might throw in here
we were stationed over there at Camp
Pendleton and we lined up one morning to
go into chow you know it was still about
half dark you know and we were standing
down and odd fierce is out in front and
there's a group come marching up there
turned out to be women and I'd first
said well man is this this man's outfit
is going to going to pot we have dogs
and then we have this group in here and
everything now we got women in here as
she's shaking his head then we heard
holding her the guy up here said fire -
for effect another guy down here
hollered back
Bam Bam and those women nearly broke
ranks ok one hair - those guys and I
found out what Bam meant that meant
brought ask marina and they didn't go
for that so they won't break rank Singh
come out of him when I first found out
that there were women in the Marine
Corps and so now you're preparing at
this point you're preparing to go back
overseas you're with the fifth the fifth
Marines yeah and in her division or
sorry fifth division who is in the 26th
Marines got it got it
and is this when you is this when you
met Bazelon back here in california yeah
his group was over there at Childline
one time and several of the guys a
that's nice alone there's mice alone of
course he is my hero too you know
so this soon as we got there lined up to
go into the chow hall like sneak over
and I said sir can I shake your hand he
certainly does they shook my hand there
was like and that was my experience with
Iceland now cabra Dartz had told me
quite a bit about Basilone because they
were he was about how for DC we 30 yards
from Basilone when Basilone was earning
his Congressional Medal of Honor you
know he was the first enlisted man to be
awarded the Medal of Honor and in the
Marine Corps and World War two and and
then you know he came back he was in
parades and
Oh bond drives and so forth and he had
it made but he wanted to get back to the
Marine Corps and working with the
Marines groups again so he joined up and
came back and he got killed at Iwo Jima
now was wasn't and we'll get to that for
sure wasn't um did I read that cobber
was actually chesty pullers runner yeah
in Guam was that Guadalcanal Rotter
canal yeah he was talking about water
canal all the time you know and I had
never heard chesty puller until cover
started telling about it and everything
and and cob reload that all the Marines
load those chesty pullers and I'd like
to observed under him but I served under
some good guys Fagan was one of them he
was you know he wasn't little like
chesty puller was but he was efficient
leader of men not and then with the so
you're back home in America for how long
you back home for getting ready to head
back over well let's see wasn't one too
long you know they I had to go to your
over that I told you I had to go to the
hospital and be treated for we called it
Japanese crude no Chinese crud and it
was just breaking out you know kind of
like I'd always started kind of like
athlete's foot or would they hold Wadley
and the only treatment they'd put some
kind of blue medicine on us and
everything and so I was over in about
Balboa hospital for nearly a month
before I was released from there for got
real there's a lot of us in that same
position you know and then back on
another
- head back overseas well we trained
over here for a couple of months and
then we was trained up for to go
overseas and we may practice invasion of
one that is Islands Elfa over here and
we invaded it you know practicing and
and when we got there we lined up on the
beach and there we kept sitting out
waiting to be told to move on the end or
something or - we said to her and sit
there and everything
finally officers came on tour said hey
we're going back on the ships we're
heading overseas Ian and so we went back
aboard ship and went over here came over
here to Camp Pendleton and started
getting ready to go back overseas again
and that's when I asked my mother is
finding me a pistol and that's when she
she came over
anyway to do more training in character
that's the Big Island of Hawaii yeah
okay
this example is called Camp toggle so we
trained and I was that's when I was
assigned to an assault squad and there
was a demolition guy and that thing and
that was quite an experience and let's
see then we trained and got ready to go
- to evil and while we were training
there at camp horrible on the Big Island
you know it land us up every Tuesday no
I mean Wednesday and give us two cans of
Lucky like or beer well I didn't drink
right there but covered loved that beer
and so I would give my - to him and he
would take and hide those
and drink history would the boys you
know and he swore me to secrecy don't
you tell anybody that I got to so when
he hit the island of iwo jima he was
kind 14 cans of beer well anyway on the
way over there actually there's a
picture in your book and you got hit
with a little demo satchel on but you
say there's no demo in that satchel it's
all beer yeah and he threw away his desk
mask and had four cans of beer in that
gas mask oh that's what it was gas
basket theater bag you know well anyway
we heard on the ship we listened to
Tokyo Rose you know we like to listen to
her because she played good music you
know and she's supposed to be breaking
our morale down but she wasn't helping
our morale she said well I hear that the
Marines but she always had with the
heard that the little Marines are going
to be hitting one of our island soon and
she said they'd better bring their gas
masks and we heard that you know and I
said cover what you gonna do I'm gonna
shoot you so they didn't use gas gas on
us thank goodness did you uh when do you
find out back then when did you find out
hey the target is zero Jima that's where
you're going when did you start getting
that briefing and know where you're
actually heading was that once you're on
board the ships yeah we we were on the
board ship for we well we got a board
ship and we sailed around that we went
over and made a couple of practice
landings in those islands and Hawaii you
know and so we went ashore the anchor
down Pearl Harbor you know and they gave
us three or four hours leave off the
ships you know so there's a group of us
together we've been in town here
in Hawaii this is not Hawaii though is
it close anyway anyway we were all that
and and one of the guys in my group was
walking around and and galkin is
everything you know an island and it's
got named Lucas it was in my group when
we was walking around he looked at he
said there's my cousin over there and so
we went across the street and it was
Lucas his cousin you know what was his
name
Jacqueline Lucas you know and so he
stayed with us and walking around there
and everything and we said we got to go
back to the ship and so we went back to
her ship and Jacqueline and Lucas was
still with us and when he went oh boy we
got aboard he went and checked in he was
on there about three days out I said I
talked to them that the other Lucas you
know so was he a civilian was jacket was
the cousin a civilian or was he had
another marine or here's another marine
chuckling Lucas was marine so he just
went aboard with us and and he was there
for about three days and I said you
better take your cousin over there and
tell him that he's not aboard this ship
where he's supposed to be with his
outfit he was gonna be a replacement in
the first division but he wound up in
the fifth division yeah he's 26 Marines
with us and he he got hurt he threw
himself on a hand grenade and and our
two hand grenades and saved him his
buddy's you know and he got the
Congressional Medal of Honor
you have probably seen I heard of him
because he and he was from Mississippi I
forget the name of the town and I just
thought I was going over to see this guy
and his in Georgia and I went through
that town and and I got past it I said
I'm Kris Kobach I see Lucas and so I
turn around of the turnaround is going
back as heard on the radio that he had
passed away there in the night and that
was last I seen I heard of him you know
then so you finish up your training in
Hawaii now is your next stop gonna be
Iwo yeah well yeah did you guys did you
guys know what did the intelligence that
you got paint the picture that Iwo was
going to be a really really hard fight
did you guys know that going in now we
didn't we had no idea what was just
another island but when I when it got
light and I looked around saw
battleships and and just so you weren't
any more nervous for that you just
thought I'm gonna go do what I've done
the last few times
no I were scared today fair enough well
you know unfair sand captain Hall I was
a runner and I was telling them before I
had ever seen any action I said I don't
know how it'll be when we said the sea
action I afraid I'll be scared to death
and everything and captain hall said
that's what you want to be you want to
be scared to death he said you should be
scared half to death and you know
there's no meaning for that being scared
half to death because I was just scared
half to death a lot of times you know
still alive
but they said when you're scared there
takes over at dumps adrenaline into your
brain and to your muscles and you react
and everything and I know that's what
happened to me because when I got hurt I
was I knew what was going on and you
what I had to do but still just scared
it I could be and that's what saved me I
think the reality did you already get
what had you already been wounded at
this point before you old who you
wounded in any of the other oh no huh so
you're still you're still as lucky as
they come right this one wounded at all
now cabra had been wounded before we hit
evil he had been wounded that brought a
canal and he got that not Basilone was
did his thing and he was about 30 or 40
yards from Barcelona on that line you
know and assailed hit him so they took
him off and he had a lot of those guys
got malaria and he had malaria real bad
and they took him to Australia and there
was a ship there going back and he was
so with that that wound that that they
hadn't been able to treat it because the
Navy took off with all the the medical
gear and everything so he actually
didn't see a doctor until he got back to
Australia and so he went back got back
to the States
and he wouldn't take a discharge and
they sent a corpsman back with him you
know he has put on a merchant ship is
going back it wasn't a Navy ship at all
the merchants it was going by and that
Corman said copy this
they're sending you home to die and
they're going to discharge you and so
cover he said he didn't know whether to
believe that corpsman or not but they
sent him up to Tillamook Oregon and
there's they had a balloon stationed up
but you know they put big balloons up in
the area with own cables you know to
protect areas you know military areas
that the Japanese would probably seat if
they tried to invade us so he got in
with cross bill cross at Birth that time
and a guy named horsefly he hosts flower
I can't think of his name but he's from
Wichita Falls and we nicknamed him
horseflies
he's always talking about horses well
anyway they were up our garden a naval
base at Tillamook Oregon and he was
trying to get back to the fleet Marines
you know and they wouldn't send them so
they was doing things that they
shouldn't be doing they wrecked the Jeep
never brought it to a head and they said
here Hornbeck their fire to a rifle
company so that's the way he got back in
the rifle okay yeah there's that's where
you want those guys that are out
wrecking jeeps put him right back in a
rifle company yeah well I'd as we're not
put in the hospital where there's a
Chinese crud and and lost contact with
my outfit and so forth and I wind up
with nails copeland and and the barracks
over there there's nearly empty
and so i went over and checked the end
and Coplin was a sergeant and so
and he was the only guy in the whole
barracks and I said where is everybody
said well this is emptied out we were
waiting to fill up again he said just go
down there and find the bunk anywhere in
the end I said well what room do you
want me to be in well the lower floor
that said there's not three or four guys
down anyway just take any any bunk you
won't you know so I fooled around there
and ate supper and everything and and
got in in the bunk hung my uniform on
the end of the bunk on a hanger and and
I was sound asleep and about 10 o'clock
the lights went on and all these guys
were hollering and singing and
everything right there I said you guys
knock it off and turn out that light who
said that big boy who said that well I
said I said and I get those lights
turned off and here he comes over war
are you [ __ ] boy so he comes down and
he was gonna fight me so I jumped off of
that bunk out of mad enough to find
anybody so here he come he was not much
bigger than I was you know because he
been hurt you know and everything and he
saw me uniform and I had my ribbons on
own everything hey your combat marine
welcome aboard come on over here we got
some there's some sandwiches and some
beer and so forth
come on over here and join us I said
I'll need a sandwich so I don't drink
beer and so that's how I met cabra
Dortch
and we'd go on Liberty together and and
they liked their booze and and housefly
liked his booze student he he he drank
pretty heavily so it wound up I didn't
drink so I'm having to take care of
horsefly
and they were dates and he and cross
covering costs would go off to somewhere
and I had to take care of horsefly well
we got we were out in olive grove or
someplace here and close to San Diego I
guess what is closer to LA I guess and
we couldn't find the taxi or anything
and I didn't know what to do we couldn't
find a place to stay with him and
everything so there was an all-night
movie going on showing porno films so we
went in there and we both went to sleep
woke up next morning films were still
showing so I got him out we finally got
home and ordered back to camp and my
experience with housefly housefly was
killed at Iwo and cover and and cross
were wounded too let's see I in the book
I told how Cobra was winded didn't know
yeah you did that's if you want to hear
that now yeah absolutely yeah I mean you
you hit the beach at I mean let's let's
just take it from you you hit the beach
it at Iwo yeah and I mean you weren't
the landing at Iwo relative to some of
the other landings that the Marine Corps
done at this point was well I mean what
was your what was your well before evil
the Japanese always tried to stop us
before we got to the beach and he will
they let us get on the beach and that's
when they really opened up with
everything they had you know and and and
it was more effective than trying to
stop us before we got to the beach or we
were on the beach and and a lot of
officers and NCOs were killed you know
off the beach so here we are laying on
the beach and
and slope and guys were laying down on
that thing and a little smarter say that
larger said over coming in like Lent
raindrops when they'd hit and this it
explodes that goes out and up you know
what it was all the laying on the ground
and not just inviting ourselves to come
in close to us you know and and so cover
said we got to get off this off this
beach so we started trying Holland get
off the beach run so was it ran man I
ran and first thing they Long Beach on
the other side that's when I realized a
little I and so we got over there and
and I heard that Hall had been killed on
the boat and I cried because I loved
that man I mean he was treating like a
son and I'd Ferris had been wounded too
but Hall got off rudder on the beach and
one of those cells he got him and I was
we were got over there and and it wasn't
they weren't firing in that area so we
spread out waiting for somebody to come
her to take over you know we didn't know
what to do so I was laying our propped
up against a deal and I heard a shot
real close to us and everything I looked
around and and I couldn't see anybody
shooting you know and then looked over
about 20 or 30 yards there's a piece of
ten raised up and I rightfully come out
shot some it made another shot so I told
the guy and over next to me and he had a
riot gun we called him it was a 12-gauge
shotgun with just a few balls and the
cartridges you know I said come on
follow me he said what are we going I
said we're going to go over and have
some fun
so I said there's a sniper in this hold
under this piece of tea and I'm gonna
raise that up and you just shoot just
shoot in there and so I raised the other
a [ __ ] looked up finding that guy cut
loose with that shotgun about tap for
what'll miss that one
god never seen nice and before with had
a shotgun he threw up and but that's
that's the first real thing I did on on
the evil you know a couple things that I
wanted to just real quick asked about
one of them was you described in the
book how the ground was literally hot
from like the lava and it was
uncomfortable to lie down on oh you
couldn't lay on the scholarly it's a
steam heat coming from up to that
volcanic ash you know they keep talking
about the sands of Iwo Jima
I wasn't said that was it was ash
volcanic ash it was like BB size deals
and it not saying yeah and it was
literally too hot to lay down on in a
lot of places and it was too cold house
I was gonna say you know in the military
we always get the worst of both worlds
yeah and you and it was too cold at
night yeah yeah it was cold at night you
needed something moving so we'd lay
something on the deck you know box or
cardboard or extra blankets or something
just to get off there and then you put a
punch over and that would hold the heat
to keep you warm but it wasn't scholarly
yeah no yes and then what about the the
razor razor grass I've heard about that
let me tell you when I heard about we
heard about the razor grass MacArthur
decided he won't use paratroopers in the
jungles of New Guinea and so they
decided to send in a regimen I forget
how many or sent in
and they took pictures of where the
warmth of the land in the jungles you
know and they found this place that the
grass in area and no trees in that part
and so forth ideal placement so they
jump in there and that was that raised
her glass 12 feet high and they had guys
all cut up on it and all the parachutes
and this grass was terrible and two of
them are killed in the Jumpman and a
couple of them landed in the jungle you
know nor hurt bad
Madelene and then they told us two guys
were never heard of or seen again they
never really didn't they had to march
out because he couldn't land to plant
playing in the jungles to take him out
and it took him six weeks to get back to
their base they had to be you know feds
along the way they have to parachute
stuff into them and so forth so that's
when the Marine Corps said hey we're not
using this fire troopers in the jungle
so that's when they brought us back to
the States and put this in now how long
was it after you guys landed that John
Basilone was killed well as well as I
remember I guess is the first day yeah
that's because I was I had to go back
get some TNT and and the guy was with me
he had to get some napalm you know he's
a flame thrower and we saw this group of
guys over there and and and a guy given
the last rites to someone what's going
on here and this guy said Basilone this
was just killed and it was a sad moment
for me because he like all the other
Marines he was a hero to us all you know
and
that was bad and then I heard that Hall
had been killed I cried again
I cried under samely you know because
they mean a lot to me you know and I
just found out where Hall was buried you
know he didn't evidently didn't have a
family I mean a wife or anything like
that and I couldn't find out worried
where he was you know where he's been
buried or anything and this girl that
found this thing pharmacy was her
neighbors Liberty Phillips and I'd been
trying for 20 years to find this guy you
know and what happened to him and
everything and I told her my problem and
three days she had this magazine on the
way she found out the computer you know
what but it was this all about and I was
amazed at that and then she found out
that Hall had been buried in well at
first and evil they got so many dead
that the hospital ships couldn't take
them and so forth so they had to do
something with the body so to begin to
bury him there and they stayed there
temporarily for several years and
brought him back to the States and he
was buried that no one who cleans it
Bobby
he was buried here and I mean in Hawaii
at the punch bowl of things Rose I'm
gonna go over some day to visit his
grave because possibility you know I
found a second cousin to him he's he
works with the
Symphony Orchestra's Orchestra in
Cincinnati and he didn't he never met
Ralph but just heard his second cousin
and he didn't know anything about Ken
folks are in things you know as we
progress through the the battle here you
wrote about it obviously here in the
book and I think this this description
here is worth reading so I'm gonna go
you're out on patrol you're trying to
get back to friendly lines daylight's
coming and here we go I brought up the
rear when we took off in a low moving
dog trot cuz lights coming so you're
you're trying to make some movement here
yeah we're not gone far when from within
five yards of my five o'clock position I
heard the bolt action on a machine gun
declaring the operator had braced it for
firing I had heard this harbinger of
death before it stood as one of the hard
lessons I had learned in the jungles
during the Solomon Islands campaigns I
recognized this telling sound of an Ambu
a Japanese light machine gun this deadly
weapon could spit out a clip of twenty
cartridges in less than two heartbeats
damn I hated that nasty little 25
caliber weapon at that first metallic
sound I shouted hit the deck I landed on
the ground at the same instant that a
short burst of gunfire ripped through
the air just inches above my head I lay
so flat on the deck that I could have
crawled under a snake's belly for Joe
the guy in front of me luck had played
out he had taken luck had played out he
had taken one or more slugs in the back
the other man ran helter skelter toward
our lines his headlong - grabbed the
attention of the Nambu and it continued
to spit short bursts at this hustling
marine while this happened the
adrenaline and sense of reasoning within
me worked in tandem
feeding off each other my situation was
critical I lay in the Japs backyard my
position exposed with only my pistol to
defend myself I took a quick peek at the
inner body seven or eight yards ahead of
me
seeing no movement I reckoned Joe had
bought the farm he carried an m1 rifle
to survive this untenable fix I needed
that rifle and a position of concealment
I knew that the nambas clip held twenty
cartridges and the gunner fired in short
bursts of three to four bullets I
figured he had only a burst or two left
he had one when the clip played out it
ejected the sharp tinny sound singled
meet him signaled me to move and move I
did I came out of that prone position
like a bolt of lightning man in that
span of eight yards I could have beaten
Jesse Owens my plan was simple I'd raced
by pick up pick up on a dead run and try
and make it to the line of boulders
about 20 yards beyond damn about a third
about on about the third step I saw Joe
move slightly the plan had changed I
opted to take him instead when I got
there I grabbed the back of his collar
utter panic poured raw journaling into
my engines I could never have dragged
him that far fast otherwise the rocks as
a safe-haven no longer stood as an
option we couldn't make it that far out
out of gut-wrenching terror I reacted on
impulse not rooted in thought or
reasoning with Joe now in tow we moved
into a slight depression in the volcanic
ash no more than a shallow dip it had to
do as duty it had to do duty as shelter
for the time being what a poor place to
defend and it offered very little in way
of protection but nothing else showed
any more promise by instincts I hit the
deck my timing proved perfect the
rattling peal of gunfire passed within
inches of our heads well I figured we
were safe for the time being then
problems began to escalate faster than I
could resolve them so this is a bad
situation here
right now man and then you look down and
you see there's a thermite grenade
that's that's that he's got on his gear
that Joe has on his gear and it looks
like it it's been shot or it's been hit
with a glancing bullet and it looks like
that thing could go off at any time as
well not only that you got the Nambu
being reloaded so from there you I think
you stick Joe with some some some
morphine and you kind of hold station
how long were you in that little
depression in volcanic ash waiting well
there we estimated it was about a six
and a half hours that we were in that
the desolation and volcanic ash and it
was kind of a slope and then the
depression and that the bullet would hit
at that above us you know every could
get you know and we were safe at that as
long as we stayed down and on top of all
that you start receiving friendly fire
from mortars mortars start going on oh
yeah they were that was just normal you
know they were throwing a lot of mortar
shells in there and and the ships were
firing the heavy stuff but not rotted in
that air where we were and what do you
think what prevented the Japanese from
maneuvering on you were you just holding
that position of the best your ability
throwing grenades and whatnot yeah
that's the only thing that could do it
I couldn't move so I just had hope that
he didn't come and then when they gave
out hope or I I was prepared I had the
pistol I was gonna make sure that we
didn't take wouldn't taken prisoner you
know because
at Villa La Bella we were on a patrol
and opportunity of us and we met some
Japs and one guy was hurt and we didn't
know he was hurt and we fell back a
little bit and then we realized that
this guy his name was Joe some I think
for the last name now and the Japs had
captured him and we dug in for the night
and they begin to torture him and and he
would you know screaming and everything
and our officers don't move don't move
we can't help him
they're just trying to get you in
position don't move don't move and
everything we sit there and listen to
him and through the night and in the
morning when it got lights you know we
went after him and he was tied to the
base of a tree with his penis cut off
and there was in his mouth and had taken
strips of skin and pulled Adolphe that
along and just really tortured him
something terrible and we when we found
out that they were royal Manchurian
Marines you know Japanese had in
Manchuria had colony up there and they
were bigger than the regular Japanese
they might have been Chinese and but
they were big guys and and we got got
back at him everyone about ten of them I
guess in that group and we finally
caught up with them but poor guy
suffered and it was hard not to jump up
and go
but that's what they wanted us to do you
know to come out of those holes because
once we got in a foxhole that night we
were not supposed to move for any reason
if you had to use the toilet where you
use dug a hole in your hole and and
those holes in the jungles with water
would seep in them overnight and you're
constantly using the tin cup to take
water out and throw it out but then the
jungle does was terrible really terrible
day you know the conditions were bad the
mosquitos were bad just jump and fight
and I hated that and he didn't get that
at Iwo Jima you know I don't remember
seeing a mosquito or having a mosquito
bite in the wool Jima and with that in
your mind there's no way that you were
gonna get captured you were no island
John already I I wasn't gonna be
captured on what I was ready to take Joe
out and myself because I didn't want him
to suffer like that either and of course
I didn't tell him that I was gonna shoot
him but I was ready to do it you spend
the whole day there and I'm going back
to the book as the long lonely hours
ticked away thoughts ran the gauntlet of
my mind early in the wait I resolved to
go down fighting
I considered surrender out of the
question and never an option
I had heard and seen the results of the
enemy's treatment of prisoners no words
can describe the pain and suffering the
Japs laid on a person before permitting
him to die while the political
correctness might these days might frown
on calling them Japs I'll call them
anything I please my buddies and I have
that right we have earned it yes when a
showdown came I intended
that the enemy didn't take me or the
Marine lying next to me alive as my
longest day neared the halfway point
through the din of battle I heard my
name called damn the voice of bul
Fischer my platoon sergeant boomed over
the other noise he had brought in a
combat patrol to find us now you you
kind of link-up and he's trying to
figure out where the NAMM bow is Nambu
is located we see you now throw I did in
the Nambu answered giving away its
position a platoon laid down a withering
barrage of small arms fire putting the
Nambu company out of business
Peter Adam got to me first along with
several other guys he directed them to
put Jill on the stretcher and sent them
on their way he said he said let's get
you out of here I'll cover you I got set
to make a run for it but as an
afterthought I told Pete that I wanted
to pick up Joe's rifle I took one last
look at the shallow defilade in the
sands of Iwo Jima what a lifesaver the
dearest plot of ground that I ever
occupied Joe and I owed our lives to it
the state of Rage Pete said we would
have found you sooner but ski came back
a blithering idiot he refused to go back
to show us the way to you guys he
reported you dead some of the guys
wanted to shoot him the bull sent him
under guard to be taken off the island
and now I'm gonna read a an award
citation the president United States
takes pleasure in presenting the Silver
Star medal to private first class steel
F Harvey junior the United States Marine
Corps for services set forth in this
following citation for conspicuous
gallantry and intrepidity while serving
with Company C 1st battalion 26th
Marines 5th Marine Division in action
against enemy Japanese forces on Iwo
Jima volcano Islands 20 February 1945
when his three-man patrol which was sent
out to establish contact with the
adjoining company was ambushed by heavy
from an enemy machine-gun and one of the
men was seriously wounded private first
class Harvey dragged the Fallen Marine
under heavy fire to the shelter of a
nearby hole remaining with the wounded
man while his companion went for aid he
held off the hostile forces with his
rifle and hand grenades until the
arrival of the rescue party then
exposing himself to enemy fire and
directing accurate heavy fire on the
Japanese position he successfully
covered the evacuation of the casualty
by his initiative courage and unselfish
devotion to duty he undoubtedly saved
the life of his comrade and upheld the
highest traditions of United States
Naval Service for the President John
Sullivan Secretary of the Navy
don't really know what to say after
reading that sir oh well that was a long
day for me but I didn't think these did
a reward I was just doing what the
Marines have taught to do you know and I
was surprised when they pinned a medal
on me there you talked a little bit
earlier about what it was like at night
and I thought this was a really good
section of the book here's the way we
handled the nights on the frontline once
darkness said in everyone went to his
foxhole orders said no one left the hole
for any reason as I pointed out we
seeded the night to the enemy from caves
and tunnels within our lines and units
these adversaries in infiltrated our
positions they sought to come into our
holes and kill with knives bay nuts
bayonets or guns some simply moved in
close enough to toss in a hand grenade
if they found the occupants on the alert
for them so we declared open season on
anyone moving around above ground to
combat this type of warfare each foxhole
comprised more or less a mini fortress
within itself the man on watch with
weapon ready sat near the top of the
hole so
had a panoramic view of his surroundings
this proved vital as the deadly
nocturnal infiltrators came in from all
directions while on watch you had to
stay mentally alert clear-headed and
responsive to any movement near your
position a moving shadow in the night
presented a target to challenge with
gunfire I had the first two-hour watch
when tired sleepy hungry scared lonesome
in home sit home sick
a two-hour watch seems like an eternity
the constant booming of incoming and
outgoing cannon blasts filled the night
air intermingled with the ear-splitting
blasts came the prevailing rattle of
machine gun and rifle fire into woven
with the Blair and the clamor of these
machines of war
you heard desperate human utterances
filled with all the emotions that life
allows when your watch ends the night
calls on you to sleep sheer debilitating
exhaustion will put you to sleep
usually a restless troubled slumber I'm
gonna continue on in the deep of the
night after my second round of Sentinel
duty a staccato of pistol fire at
point-blank range startled me awake I
leap to my feet at full alert
I could see masiha crouched up beyond
the dividing Ridge and a hoarse whisper
I asked what's up
he answered we have a visitor did you
get him I don't think so we're on your
side then I heard it the dreaded sound
of metal striking the wooden stock of a
rifle a Japanese grenade activates by
whacking its firing pin against a solid
object this whack ignites a fuse that
burns for seven seconds before
detonation beyond the rim of my hole
hidden in the darkness an enemy soldier
had to drop on me I had no options or
defense for the inevitable then I saw it
coming in a looping arc toward me
a harbinger of death the burning fuse
gave off a radiant sparkling light like
a kid's sparkler on the fourth of July I
had to get it out of the hole before it
exploded with a sense of urgency
enhanced by stark terror
i cupped both hands together I caught it
in midair and shoveled it over the rim
of the hole out of harm's way
sadly the rapid rapidly burning fuse did
not give me time to scoop the missile
back in the direction from whence it
came mastiha had my pistol else I could
have scrambled to the top of the hole
and possibly got some shots off at the
adversary but I could only crouch and
wait the interval didn't last long as
out of the darkness came a notifying
sound telling us they had armed another
grenade and sent it on its way however
this grenadiers showed some smarts he
held the grenade for about two seconds
before tossing it this delay gave me
only five seconds to do my thing out of
anxiety I reacted too quickly and
bobbled it as I hit the deck I kicked it
at the same time throwing up my arms
instinctively to protect my chest and
head the kick and the explosion occurred
simultaneously my feet and legs took
most of the shrapnel and volcanic ash
hatched by the blast I fell to my butt
to a sitting position on the slanting
side of the hole I felt very little pain
in my lower limbs but my head throbbed
with the mother of all headaches
I had a deafening ringing in my ears
accompanied by excruciating pain I
couldn't feel or move my legs i sat
there stunned F and trying to recollect
my notions another grenade landed within
inches beside me without thought or
reason I wasted my hips to come down on
the glittering missile this witless act
placed the right cheek of my buttocks on
the device my weight pushed the grenade
into the loose volcanic ash which
absorbed a great deal of the energy
generated by the blast now this one
really laid some herd on me I knew that
I had to get some help quick like or I
might never leave that pit alive help
I realized sat about 25 yards away I
couldn't stand or even feel my legs so
walking or even crawling exceeded my ex
dragging
myself with my elbows and hands appeared
my only option getting to the top and
out of a hole took just about all my
strength kind of like swimming upstream
in the waters of a flood of a river at
flood stage at the top of the hole I
lost it
I either fainted or out of futility
acceded to death I know not which lying
there in that state of oblivion and
ethereal entity began to take form in my
mind's vision out of this ghostly
apparition I came face to face with the
voice of my mother she commanded Sonny
you wake up and get to those who can
help you don't you dare give up we all
love you and need and you need to return
to us and then my former football coach
Joe Coleman appeared and he said Harvey
you sorry little [ __ ] get off your dead
ass and move out there's hell to pay and
you got to pay it
I ain't ain't having none of your
quitting now hustle else I'm kicking
your skinny butt when the old coach
spoke it came out as demanding commands
you listened and you reacted you know I
reach deep inside myself and find the
strength and power to drag my failing
body the last few yards to help and
safety thanks coach Joe at the brink of
the hole I came to a halt to alert those
inside of my presence before exposing
myself to possible friendly fire I
called out Sam
this is Harvey and I'm hurt bad I'm
coming in now don't shoot
so three grenades thrown at you in your
whole fear saved me you were able to
throw the first one back well just kind
of shoveled it back I didn't actually
catch it I just shovel it out just
struck my hand and I got it out of the
hole completely but not where our Shivan
I wanted to do you know she took back
toward the guy that the thrown it that
didn't happen and then the second one
you bobble it a little bit lands at your
feet
yes it landed at my feet I kicked it
they kicked back took me out of the game
how many days this was six or seven days
into the battle that this happened the
ninth night okay that was the same night
my buddy the dart was wounded and so
forth and you were gonna tell that story
about how he got wounded yeah which is I
mean it's in the book it's it's crazy
yeah you want to tell us how he would
how he explained that situation to you
yeah he was a good marine I mean when
the chips were down he played the game
he was put out front he was a scout
sniper that was his designation and he
had in the hole with him a young guy
that never been in action for Danny
cruel and then it was a VAR man BRS a
Browning automatic rifle so they're in
the hole covers end his poncho getting a
rest and then it was supposed to be
watch well covers sound asleep and he
was awakened by a gasp cried out you
know and he rose the poncho it's real
slow-like look and he saw that that [ __ ]
had straddled Zdenek rule and had cut
his throat
well Cobra had his k-bar knife but there
about beside him stuck in the thing so
he took three mouths and was able to get
the [ __ ] in the in the back and took him
out of the picture but there were two
other Japs in the hole and they didn't
know that Carver was under that poncho
and he didn't know that that it was in
the so he got to his knees turned and
those Japs begin to ban editing so he
got him in the chest got one long they
got him in chest three times and he had
his arms up to protect himself and one
job stuck his his bayonet through his
forearm here came out here went through
this muscle here out here and the other
Japs put the same hurt on this on his
left side so here he is flexing his
muscle they can't drag it the there been
it's out because when he flexed mentally
tied him up and so he's struggling there
well I got back up on side of the hill
field he saw this action figure that
Gobber and then the cruel that had it so
he told us a hand grenade down there and
it didn't go in the hole but it must
have done some damage to the guys that
the ban is Japanese you know
well the Japanese were scared off so
they left scrambled out of the hole and
the cover was able to get his arms
divorced from the bandits and it was
took ten accruals Bao and shot there was
two jobs as he run down the hill and he
was awarded a Silver Star for that he
deserved it
well as I told you before cover loved
his beer and when he hit the island he
had 14 cans of beer alone that night
nice night left on the 9th night when
both of us was hurt he had only eight
cans of beer left when they finally get
to cover and get him on a stretcher and
it's carrying him back now this isn't
dark of the night and they get him on
the stretchers and they take him to the
rear for help and everything and he's
having trouble because blood is forming
in his mouth his nose and so forth but
he is able to tell the guys I tell you I
forget to sergeant but it was carrying
him right but he said when you guys get
back there's beer in my backpack
plumpie dropping they run back there got
the beer and drank it and while they're
still in the hold come back they can't
find darts it's dark and he's calling
out to him and he can't be heard because
he had so much blood in his mouth and
everything so he laid there until dawn
until it got light enough to find him
well he loves to tell this story when he
gets around a bunch of guys at the USO
and that American Legion and veterans
are foreign wires and I'll take him over
the
from the hospital I'll take him over and
he tells that story so this is my buddy
he nearly got me killed
then I tell him truce or you know he
nearly got himself killed and he uses a
cart ride although that guy it was
really a guy and I guess the lesson to
be learned there as Marines love their
beer oh yeah they loved their beer now
you get and you already seen the flag
berate been raised well I think I were
raised about the third day there I guess
was similar like that but I was on the
far side of the island on the other
beach I think I'd leader did that
earlier tonight well anyway that's how
that was happened
oh I was working there was a big cliff
there and and there was a pillbox on the
side of that other beats you know we ran
to the beach over there where there's a
pillbox there and it was they had Nambu
I guess was firing that those ships are
sitting out there are small boats and
everything well we're sitting up there
and and this pillbox is on the side of
this slope and he'll than to this down
to the beach you know and so they did
load me on a rope to put a shaped charge
on the top of that pillbox you know is
concrete so they norden me down and I'll
not put a shaped charge on that and that
didn't face at the substrate so they
pulled pulled me back up and then the a
guy was with us radioed that
all that little ship out there let's see
is a landing craft empty LCI and they
had a twin barrel 40 millimeter boat
deal up there and they began to firing
the right tire and they just pump and
think they were bringing these clips
with four of those shelves on it putting
them up by and this guy would firing and
another gotta pull him off I need to get
something it was laughing and whooping
it up and they finally just drilled a
hole in that thing that that pillbox
just exploded with no parts here and
they were cheering on the thing just and
later on that day we come up to a cliff
hill thing and there was a big door over
a cave on the side of that cliff and it
was heavy with wood and metal and so
forth so I had to use I was going to use
TNT to blast it in so I put the TNT put
a whole pack on the poles and I was
carrying it and I was going to come up
the side there and the guys were
protecting me you know around you know
he Japs came out to meet me everything
so I'm slipping up on I have my pistol
that my mom had sent me I had that in my
right hand and I had this charge of TNT
on a pole and I was slipping up on that
thing from that from the side and I was
going to put that down there and put a
short fuse on it and let it blow it out
well as I was walking up her a [ __ ] come
runner from around a rock rock darling
you had a band that had come charging
anything and I took a pistol and shot
him about three times in the belly and
that's the only time out it ever knew
that I'd kill that was my kill right
there nobody fart cuz other times when
we decided the operative maybe four or
five of us firing at the same time you
know I'm sorry you couldn't play but
that was my kill they all cheered me
back over here and so I'll sit off that
TNT and it didn't faze that door at all
and so as I'm coming back and we were
looking at that guy's rifles and he was
out of bullets the one that I'd shot you
know and so about that time her to cheer
men that cheered just like somebody made
a touchdown you know and a step back
look upon her that flag have just been
raised and I was about all about 50
yards I guess from the base of that
volcanic vial king of that Suribachi and
and I thought man the war is over I
thought we've won right but it went on
for for another thirty thirty days you
know but our haze was one of the guys
lifted that thing and I knew him and of
course at one time I thought I was the
only guy on the island it didn't help
raise that flag because everybody was
sitting I was one of those guys that
raises the flag and that was one of the
last things you saw as you before you
got evacuated out I know you talked
about in the book you had them turn your
stretcher so you could see the flag
before you left
yeah unfortunately evacuated yeah it
allow us hurt these arts and I were both
heard the same night the night the night
but there was some discussion about we
were hurt that's a third died or
something
was it 39 that's a that's just poor
reporting yeah well anyway he was hurt
the same night I was and and I was taken
out to put it on
well I wound up in a long ditch that had
just used a bulldozer nothing in the
volcanic ash just dug a hole er and it
was about 100 yards long and it was just
lined with guys on stretchers and the
guys was working on them and I woke up
and I'd been doped up you know and I
walked up and I knew somebody was
working over me and they got to my boots
and I wanted my boots I was probably
there was boots my paratrooper boots you
know and he said ah one of them's no
good and I think I said I want to make
him be fixed and I was nearly in tears
you know because I was I was hurting as
unknown and influence of morphine and
stuff like that so I said I know I want
my boots I want my boots and so he took
them off and I was laying on my stomach
you know hugged those boots right here
pulled him up to me because I wasn't
gonna lose my boots are so proud of him
and then I went out and the next thing I
know I'm being put on a board I was in a
Ellis a below an LST and they were going
to take me off that board with four
other guys with a platform on cables
they're gonna pull they started pulling
up
and one of those stretchers fell off it
was metal farmed and chicken wire and
the bottom of it because it was a metal
stretcher and that went to today and it
about twelve sailors on there on the
Higgins boat and on the LST man they'd
over in there trying to get to that guy
but he just went down so fast and is
when he wasn't able to save him and so
they pulled me around to the front or
the rest of us around there was about
four or five I was still on on those so
they pulled us around and they opened
those doors are on the LST and that to
ramp down and that boat just went up
that Higgins boat just went up buying a
Texas off took us up on the top deck
pulling alongside the USS Ozark now
that's a mountain so V supply ships and
troop transports were named after
mountains so the LS the USS Ozark us
where I was taken up there and I was on
the deck it was raining and and the
doctor was going through and picking
them out they got to me and said he said
take this guy and first take him right
on the end and I said I wanted to see
the flag he said well he's up front
right tire and just like a miracle that
ship slid around on anchor because if
the Seas was really rough that day and
it was rain and everything but all of a
sudden there's shafts are light and
coming light coming through the clouds
and you could see that flag up right
there and I cry
and then they took me down there and I
still had my boots and the doctor dr.
Anderson he said take him on in there
right quick right there and so we went
in and they put me up on the table and
still had my boots and a corpsman tried
to take my boots and I wouldn't give no
you don't take my boots you're not
thinking don't take my boots and dr.
Anderson said let him keep his boots
well the next thing I know I'm an ER in
a room about this big and it's in the
room where the ship's crew lived that's
really had their bunks in there so I'm
on the bunk is about four or five feet
high here and then another bunk below
but up there above I could reach those
pipes going through there through the
book held up here so reach up there now
I'm under the influence of something
should never been given to me it wound
up it was I was allergic to it so I know
what I'm doing but I can't keep from
doing it so I grab that pipe and pull
myself off the bunk and I was going hand
over hand to my boots I was going for my
boots over desperate you know I was
crying out but it's calling from the
boots and everything I look back when I
thought I was crazy
should have been crazy or something well
anyway I get to a door and above that
door the pipes went through the bulkhead
up there and so I reached up and then I
was going through the other room and I
lost it I fell on the deck and and I
don't know what happened but I was on
the deck but I wound up in a big room
he's a big area on this ship
lit up and there was all kinds of cuts
all around here and the guys laying on
and everything
well I wake up and I'm thirsty I've got
to use I've got the other bowel movement
and I was a real Millie
so I hollered real loud corpsman there
was no corpsman and I didn't have any
needles in me you know feeding me you
know all that stuff and so I hollered
and all these guys had head wounds and
bandages on their head you know and they
all hollered and everything and we're
gonna what's going on so later there's a
guy next to me and of course he said is
here my head is over here and I could
see he was looking up at the ceiling I
said hey mate were the Corbin's here and
he didn't answer me and I got real mad
about him I said let me know what's
going on here
so a haul of real loud again and all
these guys begin to holler and scream
and everything and and I was sick of my
head and mad and everything hungry and
and it's miserable and so I gave up and
and I laid there for a while little bit
well I heard a door open
and I looked up it over here's about
thirty yards against from me in this big
room well it was a truck or or something
over there apart and they use those haul
tanks and trucks and things that are all
shift okay but this room is well lit and
all these goddesses laying on cots you
know well heard this door slam and look
up and it's dr. Anderson got it operate
on me so a holler real loud dr. Anderson
and all these guys begin to holler and
scream at me and everything and he
walked on down there and he just kind of
shook his head and kept walking you know
and and then man I knew I was in trouble
or needed help you know I said I'm gonna
watch that door if he comes through
again I'm gonna he walked he ran out of
the door on the left side so I waited
and sure enough about thirty minutes or
something like that all night I heard
this door opened and here dr. Anderson
comes in
so I'm smart I'm not gonna holler that
these other guys fading me out so I
begin waving I begin to waving
he's the walked and kept walking not
then I said I had to holler so hot I
hollered it again dr. Anderson and all
these guys beginning to hollering and
then he stopped and kind of shook his
head and I was waving at this time and
so he comes over there
he said well Harvey what are you doing
down here I said I don't know he said
I've been looking 2 days for you and I
just presumed you'd been buried at sea
and he said you don't know how you got
down here and I said no I don't know how
I got down here so he said I'll go get
him
no don't go anywhere and I said I'm not
quite a little wait for it
well there's waiting farmers a group of
about 12 guys came in and I could tell
they were doctors in Corman's everything
they started over here and they come to
a thing guys it would be two guys had
put their they had said scopes on they'd
put on these guys that were laying there
and sometimes did just shake their head
and this corpsman would take him off put
him on a stretcher and take him away and
he's working along I earned
God was hoping that dr. Anderson would
get back and these guys would come to 1b
I returned and there
shake him off and leaving lying going
around so dr. Anderson came back down
there all these girls going I said
doctor what are these guys doing they
take some of these guys out
he says Harvey these guys there's
nothing we can do to help them they have
hit injuries brain injuries and their
brain dead right now he said there's no
hope for him we can't do anything for
him so we're bearing most of them at sea
and I said I said what was I doing down
here and he said I don't know how in the
world that got you down here
and I told him that I what I'd done you
know and they didn't know what to do
with me so they just put me down there
with those guys and so he said you wait
here and I said I'll wait here
see when Elton came back with with a
four corpsman with him and they put me
on the on the stretcher and take me over
to the door and that doctor he got done
I dropped down on one knee and these
guys were working together I said doctor
if you can't help these guys in here no
we can't help them there's nothing we
can do
they're in God's hands and I said well I
guess I was in God's hand too for what
he said yeah I guess so
so said we're gonna pull into Guam and
we would be taking you off you'll be
taken back to Hawaii and so forth
and so sure enough in about an hour they
took me off the ship dr. Anderson came
down and and I thanked him and I guess
he saved my life
and then they took me to ie2 Heights the
Pearl Harbor and that's where
I was I was in a full-body cast up to
here all the way down dad split each leg
he had a cast over here too all in one
piece
and they put me in the room with this
guy here
now when you before we talk about that I
know you brought a photograph today a
big photograph of you know very kind of
typical picture that you see of a bunch
of military guys this is a picture of of
Marines clearly and this picture right
here is a picture of the 1st battalion C
Company 26th Marines v invasion and
these this is your in this photograph
this is this is your company that you
went into Iwo Jima how many people are
in this picture 243 - at the end of the
battle after 36 days I think 14 of these
guys walked off the island rest them
were wounded and carried off or died lot
of them were buried at sea because they
had six hospital ships and they filled
up real fast
and they had to go to Guam and Saipan to
be taken off flown back to Hawaii 243
started and 14 walked off the island and
I've had this picture for years and one
of them hanging then he used to hang out
with my bad never not I would look at
these guys you know and then I moved in
into my living room right there and I
would get to watch it I looked at it
every day because I don't want to forget
these guys I don't want forget
and I remember their faces but it's hard
for me to still put names to a lot of
them like darts I remember him Peter I
don't remember him officers I remember
him and and just 14 guys walked off that
Island and or is really costly in lives
and everything and I'm not going to ever
forget these guys we won't either sir
yeah which when you're in Guam now
you're you're basically in a medical
ward right yeah hey the heist was the
name of the hospital it overlooks Pearl
Harbor it was built there after the war
started you know and so I'm in this and
you get reunited with with cobber at
this point right yeah you guys couldn't
get away from each other let me digress
here I was put into a room and that
Hospital ADA Heights and Hawaii I was
put in this room with a another man than
a guy in that bed and he had a head
bandaged over him military and I was
laying next to him and I couldn't see
him and he he couldn't talk to me and
everything so I didn't say anything to
him and everything and and the nurse
would come in there and they'd take him
off and bring him back after a while and
and he never talked and I never say
anything I gave up trying to talk to him
and so forth
well I'm laying there feeling sorry for
myself and I hear somebody
Fred Harvey are you in this war just
loud you know not recognize his coverage
voice he has abortion to carry for a
mile and everything so I'm raised up I'm
in this room is about this big here you
know I'm in the bed here and there's
other guys in the bed over here and I
raised up enough and I could see cover
down and he's hauling kept hauling Fred
or this little nurse friend down there
and gotten hit his face and Biddy and he
said you just keep your mouth shut down
Tommy and she really read him off well
I'm looking for my buddy ray they said
he he said she said he's in this ward
but he's in a room on the end down here
and so it was just important to let him
down there and he came in there and
there was cover band I was glad now he's
in he's bandaged up like this you know
his arms and everything you know that it
taking over bayonets and he was pushing
bill Cross who's in the wheelchair with
one of his legs missing and cover was
pushing him like this and Bill was
sitting there directing him and
everything so cover staying standing at
the door and he said what he got was
Harvey and this guy standing here in
this little room by themselves they said
well is because of the injuries you know
and everything
why aren't out here with the other
Marines what she went over and closed
the door but she didn't close it all I
could hear him talk about she said well
your buddy over here we don't know what
to do with him he got injuries and his
legs are blood clotted and so forth so
we don't know what to do for him and
and this guy over here he's he's lost
his face he can't communicate and he
wants to die and I I kind of scared me
you know and everything so coverage said
put him out of here with the other
Marines right
and so we went up burning and the nurses
area right here's about halfway down the
hall that hole that Ward must have been
70 yards long anyway embeds are on each
side and nurses bed is right here in the
middle well they put me over here and
put this guy over here on the right side
and cover said we'll take those bandages
off of his face and nursing well he
doesn't one of them taking off they
should take him off right there people
don't have to see him he's gonna have to
live with it and so a lot seen it when
the doctor Damon and I looked over there
they took her this was all gone you
could see the back of his neck back
tires backbone and everything only thing
on his face was his eyes and he had his
ear and there's no way they compete him
you know there's nobody he could eat
anything and they just fed him like they
were feeding me to you know just
intravenously right there and they put
him over and that guy I harbor talked to
him you know I said take care of
bandages off you're gonna have to live
without right - uh sir you're with
Marines and we all understand and love
getting everything and so he took off
the badges and left the mall later and
all these Marines come by and glanced at
him and then patting me knowing and so
forth and he
a spirits rose you know and of course
you couldn't tell us that you know but
you could tell about his actions and
everything so cobber this is a
plastic-surgery reward that we're on and
the guy that headed up was named I can't
think of his name right now but he was
an all-american football player in
Wisconsin and he's big massive guy with
big hands and broad shoulders he was
doing delicate operations on on guys you
know plastic surgery and so they did
they didn't know what they could do with
me because of blood clots he couldn't
start operating on me because both my
legs had blood clots and all up into my
stomach and so forth but cobber told me
later that that nurse had told him that
there was no way to died and live
through it and not as it's been in there
about a week and and cobber talk to this
doctor what was his name he was an
all-american football player well anyway
he said is how you gonna fix he said
well we're just gonna have to build him
a new face but we can't start on him
until he gets strong enough to take it
you know and so forth and and so
coverage said well do you have something
that things yeah yeah we got a little
booklet over here that has six facial
features on it converse said let me see
it so you look at six pages with six
facial features on it so cover David to
Harold here and he took him to each bed
and had a note on our written pick out
the best-looking face in this in this
booklet something Oh voted on which face
he wonders you know and this guy you
know he was of course he was happy to be
out with other guys and everything and
he would stay in the wheelchair lock and
go from place to place God had come over
and talked to him and if you had
anything to say you know he'd write it
out and so forth
and then they started operated on him
and they didn't know what to do with me
I'm still laying there in my cast and
then one day the little nurse came up
she's from Austin Texas knocking dirty
called her name right down that but she
was 65 years old at that time and they
were trying to discharge her and she
wouldn't let him discharge she said I'm
gonna stay in here to lift wars
completely over and she did well she
came on and told me we think we might
have found a way to help you and she
told me said there's a guy and they item
in the New England Medical Journal or
something like that and he was in New
Orleans
his name was Foust and I remembered the
word south because there's an opera
written about doctor Faust you know so
I've remembered that name all alone and
so she told the commander that hospital
you know that she wanted that guy to
come over and look at me so they put him
on I got a plane bring him over there
and they look at me says well we can't
do anything until we operate on him and
he said I have a way I think I might be
able to help
yeah well they came in and they took a
machine vibrated or something and cut
the top of that cast off of me and set
it to the side and then they put me on a
table on my stomach and and dr. Foust
put six needles along my spine and you
know what a football or basketball
needle looks like needle about that long
and a little head on it you know to
screw into a pub well anyway that's way
that those things looked you know
there's needles built like that they
weren't weren't the real thing
but that's what's in there well they
stuck her nose along my spine and then
he put some kind of fluid in there and I
thought they'd should put gasoline on me
and set me afire your honor burned out I
thought I was on fire egg but oh I
thought they started kill me really they
said no that's just a symptom they're
not burning up and everything and and so
they gave me about six of those
treatments and the lace began to clear
up dissolved in the blood clots and then
the doctor started to operate on on me
and plastic surgery and they they took
skin off my legs and put it on my my
butt and everything and and then they
took a picture of me and it looked like
my legs and my buttocks had been worked
over by a guy that made tattoos on guys
looked like if a doctor had tattoo
artists hadn't fouled up and this
I think my whole backside was just black
and it was that volcanic icing and so
they got me got me up got me fixed my
lady forgetting to throw out you know
the thing and it's gonna take me they
came in and asked me where I wanted to
be taken to hospital and the closest one
to my hometown was Corpus Christi and
that was nearly 900 miles and so this
doctor said hey Harvey how about coming
to New Orleans we have a hospital there
Naval Hospital there and I can look
after you more and I said well that's
great
so I was in in the hospital sent down
there and Carver had been sent before I
did he had left and gone to the East
Coast and so they they put me on a plane
and flew me to California well that
plane was a constellation and I thought
it was used for was a hospital thing and
we got nearly halfway home and that
planes developed problems and so here I
am with a bunch of the guys that were
walk I was only one of those on a
stretcher and so the nurse came in there
and put things around me and gave
instructions to all these other guys
look wait because there's expecting that
plane to go down and so they decided it
was one to the point of no return so
they turn around
took us back to Honolulu and that all
these hula girls medicine I thought we
didn't that coming in vacation they put
on a show for us and then they fixed the
plane and finally got me over to
well what's that town across the bay the
elephant my San Francisco what is the
name of that Alameda Alameda yeah
and that's where the landed me right and
he put me out on the tarmac and I had my
hands over my eyes like that the Sun was
shining in it right there and somebody
kicked me said you little bastard the
world of the hell of you being this
copper well he had been taken to another
hospital further down the coast about 20
30 miles from that and he had been
hitchhiking
for the last three weeks hitchhiking
over every day to meet in these planes
that were bringing jaws and he finally
found me and so they they took me over
died and I I can bring up the name
without hospital he was the end well I
came so I important so the that doctor
wanted me to brought be brought back to
New Orleans
well cobber was still there
in California when I left well I was no
no no I got in pretty good shape you
know like walk around with a cane and
crutches at time and I heard that there
was a farm out outside of the over
across the river and in Algiers
Louisiana and the Navy had an ammunition
dump over there on the river across the
river and they let Marines go over there
and rehab rehab it you know get better
and then take care of things on the farm
and so I heard about it I begged them
let me
over there so they let me go over there
and with a stipulation that I would take
care of chickens because I can take care
of anything else and so here I went over
and I was taking care of chickens and
they had these white leg and chip
chickens and great facilities for him
live on they never got on the ground his
on wire chicken wire you know and they
had oats or something or planted the
seeds thrown in there and these chickens
would walk around and eat that green is
that konohana well I were to gather up
the eggs and take him in and doing that
you know well the guy that was taking
care that got real mad because that was
a cushy job but this is the only job I
could do you know and so I was taking
care of the chickens you know and
feeling sorry for myself and everything
well I had a bucket full of eggs and I'd
take him over there and then take him up
naval base eating place you know and he
took care of older eggs and so forth
well anyway I was I had a bunch of that
and I had to walk alone like using the
cane and and I heard a horn Santa right
there and guys screaming and I look up
and there's Lee darts he's sitting up on
the cab of the truck and they were
hauling slop from the cafeteria Nilla
and it was covered he hadn't found me
then he told this story well he was
shipped to an area up on the East Coast
do you remember what that place was well
anyway he was taken up there and he was
discharged so he tried to buy a
motorcycle and he called my mother and
found out were
was stationed and he said don't tell
Harvey where I'm at and everything and
so he couldn't buy a motorcycle he
didn't have enough money so he
hitchhiked down there so he hitchhiked
down there and took him three days to
get down there and he got his uniform
was soiled you know and he'd been in it
for about six days and so and he's one
of these guys that meant it had to be
dressed completely well in that picture
we tell them to tell him that he was on
the marine that ever invaded with
pressed dendera trees all that
yeah and pictured in the book where it
shows him from behind you can see the
beer and his gas mask then you can also
see this that is a uniform is pressed
and starched oh yeah and they had
initials I mean his name stenciled on
this is Spade you know here in Trenton -
well he hid it took him six dry six days
- no six trips arrives to get down our
neck I was about three or four days it
took him to get from the East Coast and
in New Orleans when it gets in the
Orleans and I don't know world war zone
a naval base down there so he has no
idea what to do and everything so he
goes to a tailor shop cleaning place you
know and that guy cleaned his uniform
you know and and pressed it and
everything for him because he had he
needed to look good all the time
so he he was walking around having no
idea what to do so he saw a Red Cross
car parked in front of a building not
there and it was a Red Cross officer
today so he walked over and looked and
there's
as lady said the lady sitting at the
desk so he has his discharge papers and
everything in 90
the FTC bag out outside say walk tonight
he looked around you know like he was
being followed the other closely and
said I've got to find a man that one
with a special mission and I've got to
find him you know it's it's a real
critical thing she said I'll help you
see got fired up and she found out that
I was over there I hate Heights at that
naval ammunition base over there and so
she said I'll take you over there sure
she closes up his office our office and
in covers holding his discharge papers
on looks or fountains you know I get to
see if I can put it on all night and see
go down through town you know and
running stop laughs cuz isn't that thing
about Big Red Cross as long as you know
and he gets him down now to the
ferryboat that's where they had a bridge
built across I so and she had called
over at the base and they had a van over
to meet him you know and everything and
so he pulls it Carl Burnett that
ferryboat was waiting on him and so
cover got out and he hugged that lady
and she had tears in her eyes and in her
part for the country Oh secret mission
yeah so he gets over there and this guy
than this thing viola he looks around
they thought should be on that Admiral
or something me no honey the PFC and so
this is car had a siren or necessary
turn on the sirens ran him down to the
town
the little town that course and got him
to the base and the gaunt gonna that guy
was gonna take him to their headquarters
office he said oh no I can't stop by
I've got to go and said I'll get down
there some way so he's standing there
and you see this truck coming around the
corner and it is just coming out and it
had two barrels of slop from the mess
hall on it and they they tell him said
hang on I'll he said I'm not getting up
our thing million flies around it
everything and so he there's two guys in
the truck so they put him
they take the C bag and put it up
between them and then he gets up on the
hood and sits on rakal brought and when
they get close to that farm where I was
they begin to honk their horn and Howard
Howard stomping the herd of that truck
hollering my hair and everything and I
was so happy to see my cry he came he
came over and really glad to see him you
know I was just like losing their best
friend you know and finding him in the
end
and so here I am and I'll take him over
there to the sergeant in charge of us on
that form that that owner of that farm
when the war started donated his farm
lands to be used to build ammunition
dumps you know there were the dump or
mounds where they dig and decided on the
ground and and had their thing there's
about 50 those mounds along there and so
this sergeant god I can't thank you for
names is in charge of the farm you know
because that guy oranges farm farm back
just like it was
after the war was over and they had to
take care of the horses on there and the
pigs and well hogs and take care of the
house and everything
well they had days used in the house and
there were six other Marines and beside
this sergeant it was that it was in
charge them so when Cobra got I took him
over there to the sergeant sergeant was
working on a wheel on a tractor and I
said hey Sarge
it's just lead darts he's my buddy and
he just got into town Kenny and he stay
here he said yeah he can stay here so he
took us in to the desk returned and
gives him a card you know to get them in
and out of the guy that had already left
so he recovers elder another name and
he's on base without not even the Marine
Corps anymore and so we he was gonna
help me with the chickens and so we take
over the chickens and this guy big
already the guy he was the guy that had
the chicken job which is the best job on
the on the farm he had to give it up and
he he was mad at me he wouldn't even
speak to me
so here cover was and on base with a for
the cards in order to let him get and
I'll follow the base and he's just
another marine didn't trying to pay you
know and so we stayed down there for
quite a while
and we decided that the chickens some of
those chickens weren't doing their job
and converse said we need to call out
the non layers so he called
a a vet veterinarian and ask him how you
decided which one was Laird he said well
put two fingers at this point and
everything we got the wrong information
he took it wrong and we killed a bunch
of those layers and he cut the
production of eggs out we got in trouble
they brought us they brought me and
because it's covered couldn't go before
the man you know and they were going to
send me back to the hospital ritalin and
its really mad and and this this
sergeant was not tired he said well let
him stay and I'll put him on the Hogs
hence so they put us on the Hogs I was
the worst job on the deal see how long
were you down there at the hospital
until our at the at the farm in total
all probably three months and then that
was that was the end of your career you
got discharged at the end of that yep
from the hospital yeah I was discharged
from the hospital and so free to go why
don't you read that round because that
introduces Coburn or what they were
meant to each other yeah it's a picture
of you two and I guess this is that the
day you were discharged yeah we it took
us out this lieutenant and this sergeant
drove us out to the edge of town and I
drink a coca-cola and cabra had a beer
and they fit both these guys loose and
and that sergeant has been charged I hit
was ended in tears he had to see us go
and so it says our faces are bathed in
sadness we had just been medically
discharged from the Marine Corps the
Corps which had been our home was now
just a memory
we loved the Marines and thought we'd
always serve the flag but circumstances
intervened and left us homeless we now
faced an unser
future however it didn't mark the end of
the friendship that had been forged and
nurtured by war like brothers we have
remained close ever since
let's it yeah and there's great detail
and in the book that you've got to tell
me even more stories and and it's it's
great to hear those and I definitely
anybody should get this book and and
it's available right now
and I gotta say there's two versions of
the book and the version that you want
to order that will have it on our
website so that people will get the
right one
it's called hell yes I do it again by T
Fred Harvey and it's got a blue cover
and the other version of it has a
similar title just get this one that's
in blue what made you decide to write
the book
well people wanted to hear the story
right there and I'd taken a lot of notes
and so I decided to write a book but
it's kind of hard for me because I had I
quit high school because I couldn't pass
the English well he did a great job
because the book and you know reading
the book it's it's a great read and then
you know you spent you spent once you
retired you said you coached football
for forty five years and worked with
kids and you still were telling me you
still work out every day
yeah I'm still get after it every day
yeah yeah weights in apartment and I
worked on the weights and I want to run
the machines where he pumped and pedal
and and I stay in shape and eat the
right kind of food and I wanted to die
happy so I'm saying then good health
that's awesome you know I wanted to want
to close out by reading one one last
little piece of the book
and now I'll just do it and and this is
this is you we went to visit Evo Dima
you went back to the island in the early
80s and this is something that you wrote
as you were leaving the island after you
went and visited the place where you had
fought and where you lost so many
friends and the book says for each and
every wave that has crashed upon these
shores since those days so long ago a
mother has shed a tear for a son who
fought and died here many of those
mothers at this time have gone to be
with their sons here pride took over you
screamed loudly and ran straight ahead
its notoriety was written in blood and
courage absent are the sounds of battle
that emphasized the human voice in all
its emotions against a backdrop of
roaring cannons and small arms fire the
engines of war are silent now uo Jima
today offers an innocuous view in stark
contrast to what took place here in the
winter of 1945 but hurtful and injurious
qualities that it supported those days
so long ago no longer are in evidence
yes the engines of war are silent here
but man has cranked them up many times
since in other lands Iwo today still
offers a landscape that features a
rugged coarseness everything that took
place on this spot emphasized strength
power and courage time and its help
mates wind and rain have erased the
scars of war on the landscape but still
it presents a paradox with a rugged
beauty about it time on the contrary has
not healed the scar
left on the hearts and bodies of those
who fought here there's nothing so
brutal as when men point their brutality
toward each other my plane is rising to
take me back to Japan I look down on iwo
as a new day as having its beginning
loneliness and sadness have crept aboard
my heart holds many unsaid words as I
can't put into words the fragments of my
thoughts and feelings thoughts and
feelings that I can't ignore a pain of
unreasoning desolation I'm engulfed by a
gray veil of sadness I leave with mixed
emotions I'm glad that I came while I
regretting the return though great
distances separate me from this island
the fault of it is always just a
heartbeat away I'm determined not to
ever forget the man I marched among all
my tears will not ever wash away the
memories now in the twilight of my years
all I've got on my yesterdays and a
whole arsenal of memories and hell yes I
do it again once a marine always a
marine that wraps up the book sir I
don't know if you have any thing else
you want to say before we wrap this up I
think you've just said it for me that I
loved the Marines and I know at some
time in the future
I will join those Marines and we will
march through eternity with each other
it would be a homecoming
thank you thank you sir and obviously
thanks for coming on more important
thanks for your service and your
sacrifice for our great nation well it
was an honor to serve to you in this
great country of ours and god bless the
soul thank you sir
thanks for coming on my pleasure and mr.
t Fred Harvey has left the building
and that was pretty pretty incredible
and thanks to everyone of you listeners
for giving us the opportunity to speak
to these incredible heroes and share
their stories and none of this would be
possible without your support so if you
do want to support this podcast and
actually at the same time you can
support yourself of course
that's kind of the way we've set things
up now echo perhaps you could show us
the way to properly support sure of
course be happy to alright first way is
or gin main dot-com again so origin
that's the company our company mm-hmm
Pete Roberts company in Maine so it's
called origin mein kampf anyway this is
where okay first first thing you want to
do to support yourself very important by
the way joint supplements krill oil
that's to me in everyday sup actually
both all of these are most of these
everyday supplements I think yeah
there's some that might not necessarily
be classified as everyday supplements
yeah like the milk name not be everyday
well yeah I guess not I would say the
one that I would say discipline you
don't need that every day yeah straight
up krill and joint yeah yeah German or
French oh oh yeah yeah that's daily so
quote super krill oil to be not to split
hairs but choco supercro oil is a krill
oil supplement and when the people ask
me still now i hade there's fish oil is
krill
what's better Croyle is better not just
because I like it better it's actually
better this is why has more antioxidants
Oh better absorption better meaning like
numbers-wise
yeah and I can go into why you want me
to I will I'm not really sure but so
Omega 3 Omega threes get attached to
your phospholipids as opposed to
increase fish oil omega-3 skit attached
to the triglycerides so there yeah that
method of delivery delivers a higher
percentage of Omega threes boom into
your situation if you know that as a
fact
unless I'm lying which I'm not you know
how it works as a fact yeah it is
there's a difference between me saying
that what I know no okay tell me you
feel better that's what I'm alright see
that's very unscientific you'd be like
okay I feel better what wait a second
honestly if I came to you with a book
and explain this to you technically what
would what would have more weight me
being like hey here's how this works
with the phosphate materials moving
through your membranes or if I was like
bro you gotta try this because if it
works yeah which one would carry more
weight with me you well know with me I
think the book the reason that you're
making actually a really good point in
my opinion the one you know the whole
it's like a social proof right social
proof oh that's like a real thing but
you started when we're comparing oil
because I told you it is you you despite
everything that the bad not tell the
truth is like I'm saying nah well you
know what you're absolutely right and
actually I'll do you one better
actually you'll do yourself one better
you told me to take krill oil
I took real IO my father-in-law's been
taking me telling me to take krill oil
for a decade literally one decade no
krill oil
no it wasn't does he listen the podcast
I hope not I don't not - because
otherwise you're in trouble highly
disappointed nonetheless I'll tell you
what it does it keeps your joints
healthy healthy joints
our happy joint as far as joints be nap
because listening with a little jingle
good the same it's true but it's two
anyway it's yeah this is one of those
things where it's like it's like it's a
marked mmm when I said it's not the kind
like Harry I just feel better it's it's
not that that's really ambiguous in my
opinion when you're like I just feel
better you know I just feel but you're
like all right Brad you don't like
there's a lot of things that can make
you feel better like you get a good TV
show on that'll make you feel better not
technically no technically no
technically for most people they're not
you know nonetheless you see at least
see them saying when you watch a good
let's say good TV show 0.50 okay you
watch Hawaii five-o yes you're saying
you if I of all I mean I mean I'm not
gonna speak for you if I watch a TV
program the whole time I'm watching your
good TV program there's something
nagging in the back of my mind that's
saying like you could be doing something
else yeah you could be improving
yourself you're right you could be
making progress somewhere you could be
prepping for a pot you be doing another
workout you'd be swinging the kettlebell
yeah I'm not sitting there going oh this
is so awesome I feel so good about it
am I right or wrong you are right for
yourself I can see how you could think
that you're watching a TV and you're
pumped up like saying you're okay yeah
that's cool well here's the thing no
still watch that TV program yeah it
wasn't on this week this past week
because there's left of the season
finale was last week so you know we're
off or if I don't know if you still
watch it after the in severa anyway my
point is if someone says it makes me
feel better better in the way they say
it is a real general way it's less
compelling then them saying like me in
my situation got it I'm like hey when I
woke up freaking I did like practice
perfect form in getting up out of my bed
for my back not to bother me super bad
to the point of it me actually admitting
that it's painful sometimes actually
it's not painful it's just like you know
you just yeah and my daughter calls your
back anyway take krill oil boom six days
a week later boom and I'll jump on my
bed no problem I fly out of bed like I
just warmed it out what about Jennifer
same
you see and here's the thing I didn't
look as much into the scientific part of
junk or fish speaking of science why
don't you explain your arm injury before
yeah joint warfare current yeah so here
this is pretty compelling it's very
compelling in my opinion - so so same
deal this is the anecdotal situation
where okay all right some of us may know
I tore my bicep tendon off the bone
again again the other side now yeah Amen
says that by scent life you know it
happens anyway so yeah this is what
you're slightly proud no the way I mean
I made it joke I thought I was part of
the joke but you the way you explained
to me that because your biceps are so
massive it puts extra tension on the
tendons and that's why they got torn
even though you're explaining it like
it's your heart done by but the reality
is you kind of got a big smile on your
face all the guns anyway no I'm proud of
the joke okay okay anyway is that real
though I think here's a more accurate
way of putting it so yeah it's okay when
you train biceps right typically
typically and some people did people
through a messenger but typically you
don't go all the way down to straight
like no elbow mobility and then all the
way up with a super heavyweight you just
can't do that every weight unless you
train that way the whole time so they're
not in corners in training in a way yeah
you can call it that and I dig it you
know yeah so it's totally sweet
bodybuilding so when you develop
strength in your biceps with size and
all this stuff when you do develop the
strength the strength exists mainly on a
certain part of the curve of the range
of motion right so but that strength is
still there big-time your biceps muscle
or super strong but when you extend it
to this flight you still kind of have
that strength in the muscle but down
there it's like I don't know it's like
the stability of the structure just
isn't as much I don't know this is me
was your arm fully extended both both
times
all times fully extended and me just
just don't flex flex harder flexing hard
yeah just going too hard you know at the
time one was in a tournament which
obviously makes sense because you're
yeah Puritan after it and the other time
I was just got too excited training with
the training partner I've been training
with for long term escalation but anyway
nonetheless tore off the bones bad deal
it's not one of those deals where it's
like oh I pulled my muscle or whatever
this is so you got to go in and cut it
open whenever they say stretch it back
down
they staple it or whatever back to the
lawn actually they drill in your bone he
told me they drill in your bone make
little holes and they staple it inside
the hole they didn't they staple it up
stitch you up so I got that less than a
week ago by the way less than a week
literally and so I'm like all right I
got a you know I'm out of the game for a
little bit I got to get back in as quick
as I can tie up my dosage of during
warfare krill oil stay the same joint
where for a doubled actually didn't
don't let almost double I was thinking
to a day now I take three and in the
morning and then two at night right it's
almost double so I do have a basic
comparison because like you said like we
know I had the exact same injury exact
same injury on the other side same
surgery same everything nine years ago
by the way I wasn't like I'm older now
so that's something too so this recovery
like giving right now is like way
quicker like this morning while I'm
putting on I'm putting on pants or gin
pants by the way I literally forgot I
had the injury just for a second that's
you know you're just like doing it or
whatever and what we're not in the week
out we're not even a week because you
were laid up for a while for the other
other one yeah nine years ago you were a
young buck you know same exact injury on
worker boom yeah and nothing that
nothing nothing for that is more
compelling then
you explaining the science behind it I'm
not saying I don't believe the science
I'm saying I'm talking to you right now
and I've seen this with my own eyes so
that's like to me makes more sense it
doesn't make yeah yeah this is yeah it's
it's to me I'm more surprised like my
wife gets mad at me it's like you're
injured you're injured you're gonna this
and that because I'm just like cruising
off the sling or whatever whose are
lifting weights not with this arm like
that's actually um well yeah it's like
like there's no pain nothing no
inflammation well very little
inflammation no matter you know I think
the like what do you call it the
scientific kind of information versus
the peer the approval you know what do
you call it's called something I said it
earlier nonetheless like if I tell you
Peter alright like oh this works for me
and like legitimately if you're a
skeptic of the whole deal like if this
works then the scientific like well for
some reason yeah if there's some reason
for me to be telling you like to do
something yeah like go to a psychic yeah
yeah yeah yeah that'll be like know
about your dumb for doing that and then
you see some scientific literature they
need more compel if it's all know I read
the scientific literature and obviously
as we were putting it all together it
was like alright let's get the right
stuff in there which is stuff that I had
used from other supplements in the past
but combined it all into one there you
go all right
chocolate supplements also speaking of
which discipline this is the one you
mentioned that you don't take every day
see I who does take it every day
Dave Bertil Dave Hill yeah hey so which
is kind of all about it which is kind of
son because David is one of those smart
guys kind of one of these guys who's
like he's an achiever that guy yeah he
met his brother by the way yeah so if
he's doing it every day there could be
something do that that's what I think
another one of those heat the way he
talked to me about it he liked it got
all crazy like big smile and was like it
I got it on it but I take it at this
time at night neck that we're going down
that gets me off what I was like dang
Dave dang even though Mike reduce the
caffeine yeah little microdose before
you go to bed oh he's probably used to
the caffeine that's right yeah well no
he doesn't he takes it far enough of
ahead of when his family goes to bed
he's like taking it and then he gets a
couple hours worth a good solid output
yeah yeah and then no but yeah here's a
weird thing about caffeine just as a
side note bra I've drank a coffee before
and went to sleep it's almost like the
coffee put me to sleep I'm not like that
no cuz you don't drink a days I don't
drink
a lot of caffeine yeah breath you drink
like a big car like the one I drink
believe me like during the muster
because we're getting limited sleep
during the muster even limited for my
standards yeah I take caffeine I mean I
take I take this right here I take this
right here I take jogo white tea and I
take the discipline but you just keep
drinking to the I drink a lot of it yeah
cuz you know busy coffee you figure what
15 per serving milligrams and then so
like one of those things I was drinking
I don't know not today but the other day
is 300 milligrams that's that's just
dumb so that if you sipped on that like
over you know a two three-hour period
and just drink the whole thing
ultimately fired you will know there's
times where I've drink like tons of Red
Bull and just been like yeah which is
why I try to taper off to the heavy
caffeine yeah you know taper off the
heavy caffeine like that's why I don't
make beverages that have 900 milligrams
caffeine because it does it doesn't you
don't need that you don't want that you
start getting it starts it starts having
other effects you stuck eat like you
talk too much
right you talk too much actually
speaking of talking too much I just met
someone that came to roll uh-huh and
they were like oh yeah you know it's
really good to meet you cuz I listen the
podcast you know he's like cool and then
we're old we talk a little bit and he's
like you're just like on the podcast and
I said well I mean yeah I mean it's a
just we're hating record as we discuss
things and then I said probably the
biggest difference between me on the
podcast and me and real life is that in
real life I don't in the podcast I talk
the whole time and in real life I
actually don't talk yeah
very much I talk a lot less I should say
yeah yeah especially with people I don't
know what people I don't know I'm not
very conversational well I know someone
I'm cool talk but so if you put 200
milligrams of caffeine rather than 15 mm
you'd be talking a lot yeah again stir
your whole thing yeah well would be
making me act out of character not a
crazy be it be influencing me in a
negative way in a negative way I believe
yeah but if you can just get in the zone
yeah it sharpens the mind I mean
caffeine is proven yeah proven to
sharpen you up yeah yes anyways yeah to
each his own you know I think
people who like caffeine they're like
coffee and stuff like they like that and
that's what that's one thing if you if
you know you might need more discipline
you might need more caffeine they feel
it if you're not if you're used to it if
you have a what's that tolerance yeah
low tolerance or high tolerance but yeah
and it let's face it
discipline chocolaty that's not why you
drinky you know tricky cuz of a cat for
you it's not why that's you know know
you'll include the caffeine yeah the
caffeine definitely it's a little
microdose to get you rock n roll but
yeah that's good
this Lynne cognitive enhancement not so
you know get for free do some stuff
stuff that needs brain output that's
that's when you take it that's what I
take it that's what good
that's when good deal Dave takes it and
that's what Jocko takes it also mulk
this is protein powder but to call it
protein powders kind of dessert
disservice mmm for sure just go with
Malcolm oh here's the thing though I
don't we don't want someone I per sign
AMA speak for myself I don't want
someone to hero a bouquet what is that
okay taste good all this stuff but like
you know a lot of stuff that tastes good
you will get good protein from bulk mmm
yes you will there's probiotics
oh no keeps the idea oh yeah and see
what's good what doesn't probiotics okay
maybe for you it's not like this when I
hear probiotics I always think like oh
that's something that you know someone's
like oh you gotta take your probiotics
right it's not something you know for me
it's I wanna take protein good yeah
proper access I'm not worried about that
yeah yeah yeah but so I never I've taken
them like a couple times before but
there's probiotics in it and so now I
realize like I feel good like my gut
feels good so maybe there's something to
that probiotic activity came back okay
so when you say maybe I'm not like that
you're correct I'm not like that
probiotics are good yeah it's like anti
banter biotics are good but and what
they're for so probiotics are like their
probiotic basically like your gut biome
right it promotes healthy healthy
bacteria all this stuff and you think
it's a huge deal ya know
now now I'm starting to realize that I
said realize I've been wrong for 46
years yeah it's kind of like it's kind
of like if I have like the metaphor
right now if I have the year the key to
life right the whole the answer to life
right what is the meaning of life I have
it I have it oh man I'm about to tell
you right but you have your plugs in so
you can't hear me I still told you yeah
but you can't get in your brain cuz you
have your foot well you put that
probiotics poem takes earplugs out balm
you got in your brain same thing same
exact thing except it's you should turn
that I own to an advertisement I think
that's just incredible it's called MO
and it is mint chocolate peanut butter
is coming peanut butter peanut butter
chocolates come on see that's and when
it's this gonna be yeah and I I think
we're good on chocolate just straight
chocolate you're good like nothing well
I've got this sample and I had it this
weekend and yes it is gob
well but I think the chocolate is kind
of the stapler is it that's why it took
a while because it's hard to nail it
right do we get taste like chocolate and
not in chocolate or something well
nonetheless be they look up for that and
that is if you're taking protein powder
and they're like hey I ain't want some
good quality protein powder forget about
the term protein powder yeah because
that gives you the idea that this is
gonna taste like crap and this is this
is the miracle it tastes delicious you
know and it tastes delicious and it's
got no sugar in it yeah also never
weight is half a gram it's got it might
have like a gram we'll put it this way
it's not full with sugar lay off the old
school mega mass 5 million oh yeah in
the big dog bag not back remember that
oh yeah yeah that's good that tastes
kind of good but it's just weird with
monk fruit yeah that's what that is so
if you're wondering like well how does
it taste not like the artificial
sweeteners that people serve up which
taste nasty like no matter what it
tastes a crap is monk fruit cream I mean
that's a weird question but like monk
fruit because it doesn't taste like you
know you use like a
I guess you know like a sweetener it has
a fruity sweeten thing like the
chocolate mint I don't know what it
looks like its raw form but I know that
it tastes freaking delicious well I'm
gonna look into that one and I will
report back
speaking of reporting back if in fact
you want to look at it this way I am
reporting back to the three people this
week that asked me what geese should I
get when I start jiu-jitsu so I know to
most of us this is obvious right now but
I won't answer this question anyway it
is an origin key and rash card if you're
doing don't keep by the way but you get
an origin get you'd get the origin key
for many reasons not only because it's
the best ski but because it's very made
in America as well and there's plenty
options on there so me saying get an
orange in yeah it's not just one origin
key I guess technically in a way you
just get if it's orange it's good and
but you have many different options
within the brand of origin yeess so go
there like I said origin mancom that's
we get everything made in America made
in America from the dirt to the shirt
meaning because if you don't really know
what that means it might not make as
much sense but when you do know what I
mean - will make sense this is what it
means the cotton is grown from America
or in America from the dirt get it no
then the shirt at the end of work
technically it's Aggie or whatever
whatever you get boom anyway made
America everything origin mancom also
there's an emerging camp jiu-jitsu
immersion camp filling up by the way
yeah filling up quick so get on that
will the space is big so which is good
yeah and yeah
did you set them at the muster was good
how big that was I was good man and it
was still not big enough I think
well we'll double it we have to yeah
we're ready to order more mats but yeah
it was gonna be awesome
you know I I sort of have an
announcement to make on that - all right
you know he's coming up to that camp lay
it on me a guy by the name of Dean
Lister the knowledge exactly just just
straight knowledge and if you come up
you get the chance to learn from Dean
Lister
and yeah that's as good as gonna get
yeah one of these guys like kind of the
wizard types
yeah you know he's a I remember
and granted lol not even a kind of like
thing yeah she's great up he's got he's
got a he's got a a gift you know like a
legit gift that people do not have yeah
you ever and I'm not even asking do you
have you ever because I know you have
probably many times what ye you're asked
Dean a question about like this problem
that you're having and you're having it
because the guy who's doing it to you to
you is just super good but you're having
this problem and you're kind of halfway
thinking actually more than halfway
thinking this is not really an
answerable question but whatever the
morning for I have in the ass room and
then he solves your problem and you're
like power have you've been thinking
about this the whole time you know all
this jujitsu stuff or whatever while all
of us have been living life kind of a
that's what it seems like
he taught something the other day and
it's from oh you know I use the crucifix
a lot sure so he taught something from
the crucifix that I'd never saw before
never thought of and he did it like it
was just like you know like taking a
breath he's like oh yeah when you get
did you do this yeah are you serious
I've been training with you for 20 23
years and you never maybe gave me a
heads up on that
and the reason is the reason is there's
so much in his brain there's so much
jujitsu in his brain he can't even like
figure out what to tell you unless you
come to him with the problems why it's
great we if you're come to the immersion
camp come with problems for Dean yeah
come with come with questions for Dean
because that's what you want and then
you can draw the answers out that you
need from them because there's too much
you can't download everything from his
brain you can't yeah
it's not like hey he's gonna teach you
like you learn this one thing no you
you're gonna have to bring questions to
him that then he'll solve problems for
you yeah that's what I do Jitsu camp
emergent camp yes 26 September through
May 2nd did you say that August oh wait
I guess I said it wrong end of all good
you know I remember that because that is
my son's birthday all this all these 26
through September 2nd two sessions or
you can say for the whole set the whole
deal yeah good deal good roster at
register at origin manor home yep Leif
is going live Pavan Dave Burke good deal
Dave yeah I'm going JJ I think's going
house
Dean when I got my surgery last week I'm
going in for my surgery Dean is there
just coming out of his surgery so how is
he gonna be as far as well he won't be
able to go roll hard but yesterday I
changed yesterday just a little in-house
little core group of guys we came in
trained and Dean came and coached and he
was shown moves yeah yeah so all this is
yeah yeah he was putting fresh yeah yeah
I'll be there kind on the on the you'll
be on the gospel yeah and the fence
there like I rode with Pete like you
know oh yeah we didn't wear before I got
my surgery but my bicep was - and I just
put my hand like this I couldn't you
just basically can't pull yeah I can't
name it this is my injury bicep I can't
pull you just have to be careful yeah so
I could do a lot of that kind of rolling
that I got it's it's hard I can't roll
probably with like you know like level
12 owners yeah less experience or
something like that you know you can't
roll me all rows Pete that's all but
basically just trust Pete that's it good
one but yeah go to that that'll be fun
don't worry what level do jutsu you're
at even if you're at literally level
zero here we have level zero people came
last year yeah like a first two for sure
it's good coming in coming in it also
for fitness gear the best fit is gear
some of the best fitness gear all the
food is gear I have pretty much on it
calm slash chuckle that's where you get
it also got on its socks by the way
freaking awesome got one right now yeah
you get the the primal bells the
kettlebells see I'm saying and when
you're looking for the information
before you start the kettlebells Isis
can be dangerous around swing around big
cannonball yeah yeah get a mishap yeah
look at feet they got some good
information on technique and all that
stuff good a lot of cool stuff on that
all right calm slash Jaco also when you
get the books that Yoko reviews on this
podcast I got am organized on the
website jaakor podcast comm books from
the episode this little tab on the top
click on there boom I got them all
organized by episode
I'll click through their ticket Amazon
and you know do your shop and get the
book get whatever else keep shopping
whatever or not whatever you like
nonetheless is good way to support if
you do also subscribe to the podcast if
you haven't already on stitcher and
iTunes and Google Play and wherever you
or wherever you listen to the puh
to the podcast because there's a lot of
podcast apps out there and I get it
it's good it's good thing vast
marketplace of podcast apps get in there
nonetheless subscribe when you do and
that's a good way to support also on
YouTube video version of this podcast if
you're interested in that video version
also we got as excerpts on there good
reason to subscribe in my opinion so
want to put on an excerpt maybe that's
the one that really you're waiting for
rather than sifting through all the
episodes and then sifting through the
episode which is three four hours songs
sometimes and then oh there it is and
then listening to it kind of thing and
you know how practical that is sometimes
so boom I put all the excerpts all the
points all the significant points and
there's a lot by the way that chuckle
makes try to put them in excerpts on the
YouTube channel maybe that's the one you
were looking for it's good witness a
good reasons to subscribe in my opinion
so yeah do that good way to support as
well also Chaco as a store it's called
Jacko's store so let me ask you this not
you Jocko that's the people have you
ever looked at Jocko shirt and been like
you know what I wish I had that shirt or
have you ever looked at a shirt that I
wear that says discipline equals freedom
never ever looked at that and said dang
I want that shirt guess what this place
you can get it's called Jacques
store.com let's we can get it
discipline equals freedom get after it
shirt the actual shirt that chuckles
wearing right now literally the one that
chuckles wearing right now you can get
that shirt represent big-time good way
to support and support yourself there's
also rash cards and stuff on their
patches hoodies hats new hats by the way
trucker hats trucker
yeah the flex it I thought you'd like to
flex it they don't like flex it actually
but I know that's that's probably the
preferred hat in the population of the
world is that flex fit yeah I think the
electric rats holds cool perfect
have you ever worn a flex fit hat yes
yes yeah you don't like that one
you don't like the convenience of this
the Flex fit I guess if you have the
snapback you just put it on one size now
if your head gets bigger my head is not
bigger or smaller on a day really says
after we were all sometimes I feel like
it's kind of bigger no I think that just
maybe the way you feel it nonetheless
both types of hats on there women's
stuff on there as well I'm putting tank
tops on there so look and be on the
lookout for that like for dudes
tank tops yeah that's already one is
tank tops on there yeah so we're gonna
get dudes going oh yeah yeah exactly
right boom summer summertime yeah right
boom show off the guns be nice sun's out
guns out beans out beanies that are in
for just in time for some we're all good
but you know some places like I'll ask
summer times cool too so boom get the
beanie also psychological warfare if you
don't know what that is it's an album
chocos album on itunes with tracks jaco
tracks and here's what is not chocolate
singing it's chocolate talking to you
every track is chocolate talking to you
and what he's telling you is reasons why
you shouldn't give in to the weakness
that you will be giving into sometimes
if you don't have this you will be
giving in to this weakness on your path
on your campaign against weakness on the
path on the warpath we're all on the
path by the way are we now hope so yeah
well here's the thing I think you're
kind of a leader on this path I kind of
evaluated this over here okay no and and
I was into working out before I get it
you know but it's the kind where like if
I didn't feel like working out it's like
I just kind of won't work out do it
tomorrow cuz I will and I would usually
you know had a thing but when you kind
of quantify it as this path and when
when when the the term campaign against
weakness weakness kind of got introduced
that's a really good thing too because
generally speaking that's really what
jams you up in in my vein in my
experience where yeah if I don't feel
like doing it right I don't feel like
doing it that's weakness right if I see
I don't feel like it then you go through
life not feeling like doing stuff and
not doing it and most the time we don't
feel like it especially as you get older
especially as you take on other
responsibilities but if you make it a
point to understand that I'm gonna
consciously not feel like doing
something understand that it needs to be
done then kind of fight that kind of
weakness there that's the path I'm
talking about and this will help you
yeah sorry yeah I think he wraps it up
to me it's important to understand that
because the more that in my opinion or
in my experience the more I understood
that the more like kind of effective you
know you are in staying on this map so
anyway when you reach like a little
small point of weakness you listen to
this album specific track that is
designated for that weakness 100% 100%
you will not give in to that weakness
that's good psychological warfare we
need to make a second album people need
to ask what they want to hear yeah what
moments of weakness need to be overcome
yeah I know had some for like smoking
yeah some for drinking
yeah it in my the way it was born was
because of a weakness that I
specifically specifically had like
something that it kind of like got to me
late you know like later on like dude at
the time I'm like whatever why should I
put this much pressure on my shell
itself is that you know is that healthy
you ever do that no no come on let's
face it it's kind of like one of those
things where it's like it's a
justification but it's like uh like hey
you shouldn't put so much pressure on
yourself you know don't add this stress
hey life is stressful don't add more
stress like this you know when it's like
it's true all right cause I'm gonna do a
sound effect thing are you ready
so chocolate white tea obviously for a
long time we've had tea bags that you
can get yeah what's that called dry tea
is what it's called yeah and jakka
whitie available on amazon real tasty
and good for you and we just got it
and put into cans so here we go sound
effects are you ready here we go this is
da Kuwaiti opening oh there you go so
now you can get chocolate white Tina can
it is delicious and it's good for you
and you know even if even if you don't
like the taste even if you don't like
that it's good for you you will like the
fact that after you drink one can you'll
be able to deadlift 8,000 pounds minimum
minimum that's the minimum yeah and it's
been proven scientifically backwards and
forwards double-blind placebo placebo
whatever you want to call it
yeah chocolatey it's it's available only
Amazon eventually will get it everywhere
that's the goal but right now it's
available in Amazon so cuz that's the
quickest way to get it out to everyone
so there you go get it
victory in a can organic that no organic
I saw it on the deal in the beginning
just because I'm impressed no GMOs no no
reason to go and drink a drink that's
gonna have been filled with a bunch of
stuff that you don't want your body okay
just drink chocolate white tea alright
books got the way the warrior kids
series and I got here's just a little
note a kid a guy wrote my eight-year-old
who read your back way the warrior kid
in January 2018
since then he has gone beast mode runs
1.3 kilometers most mornings before
school and 2.6 kilometers on the
weekends he trains plays and enjoys life
since reading your book his room is
immaculately tidy your book switched
something in him he is self-motivated
and strives to achieve we talk about one
percent in life and doing the small
things well in school and sports thanks
for your service and the book so there
you go
no big deal right can you imagine that
that's freaking awesome
a lot of the room is and that immaculate
he's on the path you know the path so
pick up way the warrior kid and marks
mission get your kid on the path if you
want to support a warrior kid named
Aiden that's making things happen go to
Irish Oaks ranch calm and get
the soap that he makes on his farm from
goat milk
he makes choco soap so you can stay
clean don't forget about the discipline
equals freedom Field Manual of course
this was awesome I was at the muster and
we're doing PT it's for whenever 4:30
5:00 in the morning or something and
this woman comes up to me and she's a
little older and she just looks at me
and she's like can I tell you something
though that look was on her face and so
I gave her the nod of like go ahead and
tell me and she's like it was November
7th 2017 and I was at Sam's Club and I
saw this book this black book and I
never saw a book like that and I picked
it up and looked at it and said this
I've never seen anything like this she
bought it and since that time she's lost
23 pounds and she said she's got her
life back boom
that's awesome so you know who you are
out there so thank you for letting me
know that that was a very cool story to
hear and I appreciate that feedback
that's the discipline equals freedom
field manual thoughts and actions both
inside if you want the audio version of
that which people still ask me every
single day you can't get it on audible
it's not on audible it's on Amazon music
iTunes Google Play and other mp3
platforms as an album with tracks also
for leadership of course there's the
first book extreme ownership the
leadership book for the battlefield
business and life and actually somebody
else at the muster said hey you never
talk about the audible version of
extreme ownership because that is
available on audible and guess who reads
it Lafe babban and me and the and this
guy was saying you you should everyone
should be listen to that it's it's it's
better to listen to it then you read it
which that depends on who you are but
for this individual he was like you need
to tell people about that that's awesome
that you guys any nuances on that
audiobook sound effects we put sound
effects in there gunfire explosions
things like that you know why cuz
emergent
immersion so yeah so you can get that
all also coming out September 25th we
have the follow-on book to extreme
ownership it's called the dichotomy of
leadership it's available for pre-order
where ever you want to preorder Amazon
Barnes & Noble local bookstore it's
gonna be out September 25th if you want
one of the first edition copies which
you do if you want to be a book book
person like me you want to get that
first edition that's cool and if you
don't order it then you won't get it in
time because the publisher won't make
enough because they have no idea they
don't understand how many people are out
there waiting for this book so if you
want it order it that'd be cool if you
want to work with us in person call
Ashlyn front it's me Lafe babban JP
Danelle Dave Burke our website is
echelon front comm and we solve problems
through leadership that's it of course
the muster leadership seminar Oh 500 5
was in Washington DC it was awesome and
it sold out yes and there's only one
more muster in 2018 it's mustard 0:06 in
San Francisco California October 17th
and 18th register at extreme ownership
calm if you want to come it will sell
out and that's all there is to it and
also for current law enforcement
military firefighters paramedics and
other first responders roll call 0:01
September 21st in Dallas Texas
one day leadership training seminar
focused on people in uniform you can
register for that also at extreme
ownership calm and until the muster or
the roll call or the immersion camp in
Maine if you want to communicate with us
you know that you can find us on the
interwebs echo is at echo Charles and I
am at Jocko willing and to the men of
the greatest generation like mr. t Fred
Harvey thank you for your service and to
the rest of the men and women out there
continuing to hold the line thanks to
you and to your families for what you do
every day and what
do to support you of course thanks to
all the force first responders police
law enforcement firefighters paramedics
and those who stand the watch 24/7 to
keep us safe and to the rest of you life
can be hard and life can be challenging
and life can contain a fair amount of
suffering but you know what it's the one
life you've got so go and live a life
that in the end allows you to look back
and say hell yes I do it all again until
next time this is echo and Jocko out